son of Osborne removes the house
adjourned from the session of February
22nd 2023. are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
president the ice happened the house is
adjourned the house will attend to a
Prayer by guest chaplain Reverend Renee
Ross pastor and teacher of the Northwood
foreign
let us pray
let us be of one mind and one Spirit
today
this last Thursday of Black History
Month
so grateful today for a new day for our
legislature to come together
to be about the work on behalf of all
who live in our precious state New
Hampshire
pour a blessing of wisdom compassion
Mercy teamwork and future thinking on
each and every one of our legislature
legislators present and unpresent today
remind each and one of them of their own
humanity and the humanity of each
resident of our precious State I asked
Divine one that you would be gracious
in giving each and every legislator all
that they need
in here on behalf of grandmothers
grandfathers Sons daughters
grandchildren aunts and uncles unhoused
other abled all those that are
marginalized
and unheard and unseen
remind each of our faithful legislators
that they are the voices of those that
are unseen and unheard
help them to be open to learn listen to
one another as they work together on the
behalf of our precious state New
Hampshire
I thank you today for giving each one
courage
to be all that you intended them to do
rather than what they have settled for
in unconditional love for all
do you recognizes the member from
Manchester representative Damon Ford who
[Music]
here
the chair wreck the chair recognizes
Reverend Robert Thompson of The
Sovereign Souls Fellowship Church in
Manchester who will now sing our
oh say can you see
by the dancer
[Music]
foreign
wave
oh the land of the streets
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker uh just a quick
moment and I'm trying not to have a
moment um our Our Guest chaplain today
Reverend Renee is the daughter of the
first African-American to serve in the
New Hampshire House of Representatives
The Honorable Henry Richardson and we
are so honored to have her with us today
and and uh her family is with us in the
gallery so please let us thank
[Applause]
the house will tend to request for leads
of absence
Mr Speaker the day Representatives
Bartlett foot Judy Khan lewicki Mason
Mills esophagitis Thomas Walsh the day
important business Representatives
Burros bouillard cascaden Cole conlon
janvan Kaczynski Wayne McDonald McLean
Minier
O'Hara Schultz Southworth trottier and
Varney
these leaves of absence shall be granted
unless otherwise ordered by the house
the house will attend to introduction of
guests Mr Speaker please welcome Marcus
Hudson guest of Representative Morton
Joseph and Liv de Lin Michaela pelino
and Judy Sheehy guests of Representative
Lloyd Matthew Dan and Angela Brown
guests of Representative rum and Kyle
Moulton son of Representative Moulton
there with us in the gallery today
Welcome to the New Hampshire house
[Applause]
the house will now attend to the
continuation of the regular calendar
beginning with the special water house
majority of the committee on education
to which those referred house bill 35.
an act requirements student
identification cards to include the
national Eating Disorders hotline and
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment a recommendation
to Bill ought to pass with amendment is
then of Oliver Ford for the majority of
the minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
falling resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate Senator Mike
Belcher for the minority of the
committee the amendment is zero two
eight nine age printed in house Record
12 page 36. are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say aye
those opposed name
the eyes have it the amendment is
thank you Mr Speaker honorable members
first of all I rise today in
congratulations
to the namesake and young man who this
bill will be named for who is with us
today in the audience
for being a part of this legislative
process which we all know is difficult
my message to this young man is
regardless of the vote outcome today you
have succeeded
you have succeeded because you have
brought this issue to this house floor
for debate thereby raising awareness for
it
on that I would say congratulations and
job well done
now I must speak for the minority of the
committee for some concerns we had about
some of the specifics in the bill
first when it comes to the adding of a
new number to an ID card it's important
to note that we currently have a mandate
that there is a universal mental health
and crisis line on each ID card
this line is staffed 24 7.
by operators that are well trained to
triage incoming calls
provide the appropriate follow-ups
and if necessary get emergency services
to the individual making the call
in questioning we heard
that there is uncertainty as to the
Staffing hours of this specific
hotline for eating disorders
we're unsure of the training
for the Personnel on the other end of
the line
we are unsure of the triage capabilities
and we are unsure of their their ability
to provide emergency services for crises
I would
compare
this proposed legislation
to our current 911 system
we have a system we're in in New
Hampshire if you dial 9-1-1 you reach an
operator
who is trained to triage the incoming
call
and provide whatever emergency services
are necessary to your location
before we had this system each Town had
separate phone numbers for police for
fire and for EMS
and there is a legitimate concern that
adding additional con condition specific
numbers to an ID card would be a step
toward the old method of doing things
instead of the universal line that is
and it is for those reasons that I would
recommend against the OTP motion
but nonetheless provide thanks to the
sponsors and the young man involved
speaker
last fall a constituent of mine from
Merrimack Matthew Brown who is in the
gallery with his parents this morning
he's a 14 year old freshman at Merrimack
high school and he asked me to file a
bill to add the Eating Disorders
helpline to student IDs
he was very concerned about the
prevailence of Eating Disorders among
his peers and other young people
when I asked Matthew to describe this
problem to me his answer was astonishing
almost 30 million Americans suffer from
an eating disorder many being people
between the ages of 12 and 25.
students and adolescents with eating
disorders are among the most likely to
experience suicidal ideation and medical
complications and those with severe
symptoms are 11 times more likely to
attempt suicide
these young people don't see that as a
mental health issue they don't see it as
to a point where they would call a
suicide hotline they only see and
recognize that they have an eating
disorder
by promoting the Eating Disorders
helpline on their school IDs students
will have communion access to connect
to the early treatment they need to find
helpline available is an is important to
friends and family
who were often the ones to seek the help
for their loved one
the national Eating Disorders
Association provides counsel and
guidance for friends and family on how
to effectively intercede
many of us know the helplessness in
watching someone we care for continue
down a self-destructive path a path that
early intervention before it ever gets
to Suicide ideation
how that path to early intervention and
treatment can turn things around
disorders are complex they're dangerous
and they're common
this bull provides students access to
help that is specifically responsive to
the uniqueness of this issue
the 988 hotline is certainly valuable
but the Eating Disorders helpline
addresses a different need
in closing I want to thank Matthew Brown
for his initiative and energy in getting
HB 81 to this floor today
his testimony in front of the house
education committee was so compelling
and impressive that the title of HB 81
was amended by the committee
at to be known as the Matthew Brown Act
please join me in voting ought to pass
as amended on HB 81 the Matthew Brown
a division has been called members take
and turn on your stations if you haven't
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently second it is sufficiently
foreign
the motion before us is ought to pass
with Amendment on House Bill 35. this is
a Walt the house will be in order
this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Belcher for a
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that the objective here to raise
awareness for the very real issue of
Eating Disorders has been achieved
through floor debate and if I know that
currently there is a universal mental
health line on all student ID cards that
serves this function should I now press
the red button
do I recognize representative Ladd for
and thank you very much Mr Speaker
if I know this bill places the Eating
Disorders helpline phone number on
student identification cards
and if I further know Eating Disorders
among students in grades 6 through 12
have become a tragic and devastating
reality
and if I believe that by placing this
help number on student IDs it will help
save lives families and future
Generations
would I then support the Matthew Brown
act by pressing the green button thank
you
the motion before us is on the majority
report of autopaths has amended on House
Bill 35. this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press a green
button if you opposed or press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
foreign
McAleer
representative
wall members president had the
opportunity to vote I also attend the
238 voting a 105 voting a the motion
carries
Mr Speaker
what reason to memorize
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker because
of the excellent debate on both sides of
the island this bill I would ask it to
be placed in the permanent Journal
committee on the executive Apartments
foreign
executive departments and administration
to which was referred House Bill 180 an
act renaming Columbus Day as indigenous
people's Day considered the same report
the same with the following Amendment
recommendation to build a lot of paths
with Amendment representative J.C Grotti
representative McGuire is recognized for
thank you Mr Speaker I moved to table
house bill 180.
it is a proper motion the motion before
us is the table house bill 180.
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
op close nay the eyes have it and the
bill is laid on the table
I'd like to make special
mention that the Brown family is up in
on the on the last bill 35 we just had
this
[Applause]
committee on Health and Human Services
and elderly Affairs to which was
referred House Bill 338 FN act relative
to prescription drug assistance for
individuals diabetes considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate
there is no debate but we have had a
request for a roll call by
representative senator natasto
and it is properly seconded
members take your seats this will be a
okay
the motion before us is the inexpedient
to legislate
on House Bill 338 this is going to be a
roll call voter chair recognizes the
representative Leon for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill tries to use a prescription board
that does not exist has not been stood
up and is not funded in order to achieve
what is a honorable reason but one that
would be completely unworkable would I
then press the green button to support
itl so that this need for insulin at a
reasonable price can be met in a
the motion before us is the inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill 338 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
or press the red button voting stations
[Music]
representative Ladd representative
cornelli
um
well members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
283 voting a 61 voting a committee
committee on Judiciary tuitions referred
cacr6 not regulating to the retirement
age for judges providing that mandatory
judicial retirement age shall be
increased from 70 to 75 having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation of the bill ought to
pass
representative Kathleen catawb for the
committee chair recognizes
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise in support of cacr6 a proposed
Constitutional Amendment that will
increase the mandatory retirement ages
for judges in New Hampshire from age 70
to age 75.
this is a bipartisan proposal
and I am honored that the person who
co-sponsored this bill with me is the
ranking member of the other party in the
other chamber the well-respected senator
from Manchester
this bill also received overwhelming
bipartisan support from our Judiciary
Committee
the 70-year age limit for judges has
been a part of the New Hampshire
Constitution since it was first adopted
in 1784.
at that time the average life expectancy
in this country was 38.
so at that time not many prospective
judges were likely to be affected by the
age limit
things are much different today average
life expectancy is now
76.4 years with women having
approximately six year greater longevity
than men
so now the age limitation does have real
consequences for our state in terms of
the loss of service of Highly qualified
and experienced judicial officers
let me stress here that this is a very
Modest Proposal
as you know under the federal system
there is no age limit for judges
I believe that that is a mistake because
not only with respect to judges but with
respect
to all occupations there does come a
point at which the likelihood of
diminished mental capacity resulting
from age makes it prudent to preclude
further service but I respectfully
submit that in today's world age 70 is
simply too young to impose such a
restriction
as proof of this point I asked how many
people in this room are over 70 and
believe that you are no longer competent
let let me give you three brief examples
of what I mean
Ken McHugh
a Democrat appointed by a republican
Governor John sununu
served on the superior court for many
years until he was forced to retire when
he reached 70.
he was a wonderful judge who had an
uncanny ability to read people and
understand human emotions
he is now 78 years old and when I saw
him at a dinner a couple of months ago
it was quite obvious that he is still as
sharp and focused as ever
Rich McNamara was the first Superior
Court Judge appointed to staff the
business court docket
he is a republican appointed by a
Democratic governor John Lynch
he served for a little more than 10
years before he also turned 70 and had
to retire
he is a genuine legal scholar who
literally quite literally wrote the book
on New Hampshire criminal practice and
is the person largely responsible for
developing the business Court the highly
the business court docket into the
highly respected docket that it is today
finally the most tragic loss of talent
the age 70 limit hate limit has imposed
is the forced retirement of Carol Ann
Conboy
Carol was an independent first appointed
to the Superior Court by Republican Judd
Greg and later appointed to the Supreme
Court by Democrat John Lynch
I had the pleasure of working closely
with her for more than a quarter of a
century
she is the epitome of everything one
could want in a judge
smart hard-working fair-minded and
empathetic
in an earlier life she had been an
English teacher
and the rest of us on the court would
Marvel at her ability to catch and fix
our there to for unnoticed grammatical
faux pas before our opinions were
cleared for release
if the proposed Constitutional Amendment
had been in effect the citizens of New
Hampshire would have had the benefit of
the service of each of these judges for
five additional years
this amendment will not be retroactive
and therefore comes too late for them
and for any other judges including
myself
who are already 70 or who will turn 70
before the amendment if approved by the
legislature can be voted on by by the
citizens in November of 2020 of 2024 and
I should note just so that it's clear I
will be 75 by November of 2024 too so it
has absolutely no effect on me
but what I suggest to you is please
let's not let the benefit of uh of the
five years of additional service be lost
to any more experienced judges in the
future after November of 2024. I
respectfully asked for your support of
this bill and Mr Speaker because this
proposal requires a 60 affirmative vote
I asked for a division thank you Mr
Speaker
oh
representative cancer questions
for customer roll call is that's
officially seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
[Music]
members take your seats it's the roll
this requires a total vote of the
Three-Fifths of the membership
so everybody's clear
the motion before us is ought to pass on
cacr6
this is going to be a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative Lynn for
this is the motion before us is ought to
pass in cacr6 this will be a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button your opposed you'll press a
red button voting stations are open for
foreign
[Music]
for our members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend a state
a vote of 321
yays 27 days it passes by the
Three-Fifths
majority
representative luno declared a conflict
committee on Judiciary to which was
referred House Bill 63 and act relative
to religious use of land and structures
considered the same report the same with
the falling resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate Senator Jeffrey
Gleason for the committee are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye aye as opposed nay
[Applause]
division has been recalled members take
the motion before us is the committee
report of inexpecting to legislate on
House Bill 63. this will be a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your poster press the
red button voting stations are open for
okay
bad
representative Raymond
all members president had an opportunity
to vote I also attend the state of the
vote
189 voting yay 158 voting Aid committee
report is adopted
all right Mr Speaker on this one
represent
ative the committee on Judiciary to
which was deferred House Bill 240
relative to equal access to marriage
this comes to us without recommendation
representative Macbeth moves ought to
pass
representative Amman requests a division
this will be pis only
the motion before it's a lot of pass on
House Bill 240 the chair recognizes
representative Airman for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that marriage is a
Cornerstone of our society and that our
state's statute should clearly Define
that the state should not issue
licenses on the basis of race and that
if I further know Mr Speaker that the
state should never discriminate based on
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 240 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposer press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
the Royal member's president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
218 voting a 132 voting United committee
representative
majority of committee on Judiciary to
which was referred House Bill 254 and
act relative to remote participation in
public meetings under the right to no
law and considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolves that is inexpedient to
legislate Scott Wallace from the
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
Senator Mark page for the minority of
the committee
are you ready for the question
oh all those in favor say aye
the eyes have it and committee report is
adopted
committee on Judiciary to Richard's
referred House Bill 256 in Acts
prohibiting cities and towns from
discriminating in the use of public
facilities having considered the same
report the same with the falling
resolution that is inexpeding to
legislate Senator Marjorie Smith for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
Paul's name
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted
majority of committee on Judiciary to
which it was referred House Bill 308 act
relative to Lake Warren for meeting open
to the public to include remote presence
and considered the same report the same
the following Amendment recommendation
of the bill ought to pass with Amendment
Senator Bob Lin for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate Senator Lewis
Louisiana for the minority of the
committee
the amendment is zero two four oh
pretending house Record 12 Pages 43 44.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
op close nay the eyes have it and the
amendment is adopted the chair
foreign
good morning everyone
is Andrews Merrimack County District 5.
I am here today in opposition
of the hospital 308.
if remote it could be a hundred percent
for those that want remote and the
citizens
I would consider it
[Music]
but
this will
allow for less than Aquarium to
participate in a public meeting remotely
with state boards
state boards is described in the
amendment
meeting remotely is not equitable
and is not a hundred percent attainable
remote participation by state board
committee members again is not equitable
as not every member or the public has
internet access for example I know in my
town citizens on North Road just
obtained adequate internet and it took
two years to obtain
we have many areas of New Hampshire that
still don't have excessive accessible to
really great internet
equal access to a public meeting has to
be a hundred percent to both the State
Board committee members and members of
the public anything less is unacceptable
there should be a standard of functional
equipment
what is considered functional equipment
when a person accepts an appointment is
this better
okay our nomination to a board that
person knows that in-person attendance
is expected
until the day arrives that every citizen
of New Hampshire has sustainable
internet access remote attendance should
not be allowed as a way to conduct
public meetings as we all
work for the citizens
part one article 8 of the New Hampshire
Constitution says all power residing
originally in and being derived from the
people
all the magistrates and offices of
government
are their substitutes and agents and all
time accountable to them
government therefore should be open
accessible accountable and responsive
to that end the Public's right of access
to governmental proceedings and Records
shall not be unreasonably restricted
section one of RSA chapter 91a reflects
this purpose when it states
openness in the conduct of public
business is essential to a Democratic
Society
the purpose of this chapter is to ensure
both the greatest possible public access
to the actions
discussions and records of all public
bodies and their accountability to the
thank you Mr Speaker
House Bill 308 seeks to enable but not
to mandate that state boards committees
councils and like State bodies may vote
to allow remote participation when being
physically present isn't reasonably
practical for a member
this does not apply to the general court
nor any Committee of either house nor
the governor nor the executive Council
it requires that one-third of the total
membership be physically present in the
in person at the meeting location
passing this will better enable people
from all four corners of our state to
participate on boards
so that we may get the best in most
qualified people on our boards not just
the ones who happen to live closest
this will enable remote attendance when
needed in cases such as members with
disabilities who have struggled to make
Quorum as is the case with a special ed
advisory committee which is required to
be maintained under federal law and to
have a majority of members with
disabilities or be parents of children
with disabilities
this will also allow Physicians who may
be on call and need to be near their
Hospital in the case of an emergency to
participate on the rare disease advisory
Council and the traumatic brain injury
Commission
I ask you to vote otpa on this bill for
the benefit of allowing boards to make
their own decision on this important
issue as my fellow rep from Windham
likes to say rep McMahon let's get this
the motion before us is auto pass as
amended on House Bill 308.
a division has been requested members
foreign
308 this will be a division vote chair
recognizes representative catawb for a
chair recognize representative Lynn for
sorry thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that this bill with
the amendment we have just approved
permit state boards commissions advisory
councils Etc to choose to but not to be
required to conduct meetings wherein
some of its members May participate
remotely as long as at least one-third
are physically present and all members
are able to see and hear and be seen and
heard by all other members of the board
and by members of the public attending
the meeting at the meeting site and if I
know that this bill applies only to
meetings of state boards commissions Etc
but not to meetings of local or County
boards or commissions not to meetings of
the legislature or any legislative
committee nor to meetings of the
governor and Council and if I also know
that we have received evidence from
various state boards and commissions
indicating that their ability to operate
effectively and to carry out their
assigned responsibilities is being
significantly adversely affected by the
requirement of physical presence of all
or most members at each meeting
than what I support the otpa
recommendation of the overwhelming
majority of the Judiciary Committee by
pushing the green button thank you Mr
Speaker
motion before us is the majority
committee report about a pass out
Amendment on House Bill 308. this is a
division vote here in favor you'll press
the green button of your opposed or
press the red button voting stations are
foreign
had an opportunity to vote
222 voted day 127 voting Aid the
so
uh
majority of the committee on Municipal
and County government to which was
referred Hospital 44 an act relative to
permissible residential units in the
residential Zone having considered the
same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation to build
what a password Amendment Senator Julie
Gilman for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate it's another
one turricot for the minority of the
committee the amendment is zero zero two
nine H printed in house Record 12 page
36. are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say aye
all supposed name
the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted
the chair recognizes Representatives
as you can tell I'm very new at this I'm
hoping not to screw it up the member
will suspended
all right and then when they continue
right now
I can't hear it so the member may
continue
I have been told my my uh most esteemed
colleague to keep it brief and so I will
one of the things that bothers me about
this bill is that oh and by the way I'm
Carrie Speer I recommend I represent
Nashua Ward 3.
and I'm against this bill and the reason
why is that it singles out very specific
towns and the towns include towns like
Manchester Nashua Rochester Portsmouth
Dover and a few others because simply
because they have sewers
my background is engineering so what I
did was I investigated this condition of
the sewers of at least the major towns
that's Nashville and Manchester
both those sewer systems are absolutely
stressed to capacity so to assume that
we can automatically just
quadruple the number of houses on some
very small Lots
without any investigation is not valid
I can I wrote down three pages of
Investigation I'm not going to read it
but that is a fact
the other problem we have is that Nashua
and Manchester their public water
systems are also stressed to capacity
water pressure is down at the level
where if you take a shower and someone
else flushes a toilet in the house
you're going to lose your water pressure
we that's all we have that's about 28 to
30 pounds
most uh equipment like washing machines
dish dryers and those sort of things
require or recommend 60 pounds of
pressure to keep the valves working
properly so we have water pressure
issues we have parking issues Nashua
only says one and a half Cars per
apartment
that means one of you is taking a
tricycle to work
we have laws on the books that say
municipalities and I can quote the law
but I'm not going to but that
municipalities have the right to set up
their zoning the way they see fit for
the communities and the densities and
the populations that they have we spoke
yesterday about
about that kind of an issue uh a number
of times that is to say that we didn't
want to step on municipalities when we
don't know the details of what those
municipalities are going through and
that's exactly what this bill does
I have been assured by my esteemed
colleague who I Revere that there are
towns that don't have zoning laws
and maybe that's a way to attack this
but Nashua Manchester and a number of
the other towns that I mentioned are so
overpopulated diversity has been
mentioned Nashua and Manchester are the
most diverse towns that we have in this
state
uh I think on that point I'm going to
let it go I've said my points and I just
want you to be assured that it's not
that we don't want housing we need
housing Nashua is building 160 a 240
unit building that's replacing a 48
building housing effort that they had
already they took it down and built
another one they've got others on the
plans but in those plans they also plan
for expanding and trying to improve the
sewer system
monies had to be allocated we're talking
about millions of dollars in order to
upgrade those systems just to
accommodate the buildings that they have
planned all of a sudden trying to throw
in a bunch of uh
independently decided quadruple quad
plexus into various small wedging little
areas doesn't help the sewers and
doesn't help any kind of planning
I've saved my whole life to be able to
buy my house to have my house free and
clear of a mortgage by the time I retire
next door there's a rental
I don't want what I've saved my whole
life
to the the value of that house to go
down such that I can't take the equity
out when I need it I know that's selfish
but that's what we're doing to the
entire area by allowing these these
little properties to be split up
I would like to end on this one note
when New York City Gramercy Park
planners designed the rebuild of the
World Trade Center
after careful research they decided that
a top priority for the well for the
well-being of the neighborhood was to
include more Open Spaces not less
and that's in an area where each square
foot of land is worth more than I
probably earned in my lifetime
so just think of that when we when we
take away and Destroy every piece of
green area that we have
and think carefully about that thank you
chair recognize representative Bogart
[Music]
I represent Laconia
okay in this deal I've also had 25 years
in working with zoning boards in two
different states 20 years in New
Hampshire in five years and the State of
Florida okay
um
with working with zoning
you know I've looked at this bill and
this bill will force many of the
municipalities to permit as a matter of
right
a matter of right
that's a key word
okay
to build four units on any single family
lot
okay now if you look at this it's also
caveat with the ability for them to have
sewer and water so now we're narrowing
the scope to cities and towns that have
uh sewer and water okay so most of these
cities and towns have already been
mostly built out so we're not looking at
a lot of land that has single family
residential
designations on them what you're looking
at is already developed
areas of residential areas
that have been built
now the other part of this Bill is
saying that we're doing it to improve
housing
well
in one sense it would increase housing
but on the other sense if you took an
established neighborhood that had a
couple of houses that need to be
refurbished or upgraded or whatnot these
are the types of homes that your
that's what they can afford and then
they invest their life into these homes
to upgrade in them and bringing them up
to Neighborhood standards and then
hopefully one day being able to sell it
for a profit
which is the American dream okay a own
in your home and B being able to sell it
for a profit
so now let's imagine these same homes in
your neighborhood
that now an investor
someone who don't even care to live
there
has no investment in the neighborhood no
investment in the character of the
neighborhood
are the value they don't care they're
looking at how can I profit mostly from
the property
so knowingly they come in they buy this
property they tear the house down
and then build a quad Plex four units
whatever they wish
if you look at also this bill what it
does because remember that word right
it takes it out of anybody's review
so all those people who live in these
neighborhoods who have invested their
life in these neighborhoods have now had
their opinion of how the character of
the neighborhood should look
that have no recourse to talk to any
government they have no recourse to talk
to their city council that have no
recourse to talk to their locally either
elected or appointed zoning board
they have nothing
except to have to accept the will
of Big Brother telling them how they're
now going to live
is this what we do in New Hampshire I
don't think so
I think one of the greatest things as I
stand here before this great
legislative body is the fact that do we
always agree no but we have great
debates
and I get chill bumps every time we have
these great debates okay and so when you
come down to the city level which this
isn't also infringent on this City's
level to determine how their communities
are going to be
okay it's taking that right away so you
have a state level trying to dictate
what the cities should be required to do
and if it was such a great Bill why do
you take all the people's opportunity to
voice opposition away because you
[Music]
how would you feel if the federal
government come down and said well we
want to Trump yours and we want to tell
you how you're going to live
New Hampshire would not put up with that
nor should New Hampshire have to put up
therefore I ask that you vote no
on ought to pass
thank you as a member of yield the
questions
no member does not yield
thank you Mr Speaker
House Bill 44 re-legalizes as in makes
them legal again building types that we
love in historic neighborhoods
fully using infrastructure already in
place what this bill does it is it
allows up to four units to be carved out
basement or attic Apartments returning
an old Victorian home to multiple condo
units allowing for more housing only in
properties serviced by Municipal Water
and Sewer only
in family single-family residential
zones this is infill housing
this is not an affordable housing bill
this is a more housing Bill we heard a
report from the New Hampshire
housing.org that it would take at least
000 units to achieve a balanced housing
market in New Hampshire right now there
are less than 1 000 units available for
sale on the multiple listing service you
can't fix what you don't face to fix our
housing shortage we must face it head on
we've been here before this legislature
passed a bill to allow accessory
dwelling units and gave municipalities a
year to decide how to implement
accessory dwelling units locally
this bill is absolutely also subject to
local control just like accessory
dwelling units were
you've heard that municipalities can
solve the issue of needing 20 000 units
on their own respectfully can solve a
problem and will solve a problem are two
very different things we are in this
situation because for decades
municipalities have moved to
exclusionary zoning creating
single-family requirements where we once
allowed Property Owners to house
multiple families Under One Roof
according to the mercatus institute at
George Mason University states are
within their rights to preempt local
governments when the key levers to
achieving a major State goal twenty
thousand housing units are held
unfortunately at the local level
the state building code is a good
example setting a baseline for health
and safety even though the structural
soundness of a building is a local issue
in contrast solving a Statewide lack of
housing addresses a broad problem and
should be solved by us the elected
legislators for the entire State nobody
else is going to step in and correct the
balance this is problem for us to solve
we are the ones that we have been
waiting for this legislature has the
power to address our current housing
crisis and pass this good housing Bill
your own municipalities will determine
how they want to implement parking
requirements Architectural Review
standards lot coverage and for the
representative from Nashua water
pressure requirements zoning codes to
solve your own local challenges towns
still have control there are grants
available right now from the New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority to
give towns money to update these zoning
ordinances this is also a jobs Bill
people who choose to add a unit to their
property were higher local trades
Carpenters plumbers electricians who
live right here and want to work on
their neighbor's properties to renovate
and that money stays here in the New
Hampshire economy
it is our duty as legislators to fix
this and pass this good housing Bill
thank you
foreign
order
thank you Mr Speaker good afternoon
colleagues I re rise to speak in
opposition to the motion of OTP this
legislation would mandate arguments
municipalities to allow as a matter of
right for dwelling units on a
residential lot with access to Municipal
Water and Sewer I want to make two
points based on discussions uh within
our Committee hearing the first one was
a young man who came and testified
that he owned a property in the North
he said his Free Will should allow him
to do whatever he wants to do on that
piece of property
so I asked the young man I said how long
ago did you buy your property and he
said two years and I said when you
bought that property did you buy that
property based on your own free will
and he said yes
and I left the questioning there because
my point was you bought that property on
your own free will you should also know
the regulations that you bought that
property under
and I'm familiar familiar with the North
End of Manchester at least a couple
neighborhoods because my mom and my
grandmother grew up there in a
neighborhood of almost 70 that's about
70 years old
the second question I asked was why Lots
Without Water and Sewer were exempt from
this bill
and I brought up the point in my town we
have an 80 000 foot square 80 000 square
foot lot minimum
why if the well resources were good
and why if we were able to have adequate
leaching
why was that not acceptable
and the answer I received was to
maintain the rural characteristics
so here we have a classic example of
nimbyism not in my backyard for those
who are unfamiliar with the the term and
I would take it one step further than
that I'd call it a little bit on the
hypocritical side
are not the owners of these residential
neighbors neighborhoods also entitled to
their neighborhood characteristics
without their neighborhoods being forced
into these mandates
now speaking of unfunded mandates many
on our committee and several who
testified and you've heard a little bit
about it today we're talking about the
demands on the municipal water and sewer
system that they would increase
significantly and of course that's true
who's going to be required to foot the
cost of this is going to be the towns
there's going to be the taxpayers it's
going to be the cities who's going to
pay for that
and more importantly when those costs
come up
are the supporters of this bill today
going to be coming back to this body
and asking for all the state's taxpayers
to pay for the upgrades in their towns
also I'd like to talk about I think how
this this bill picks winners and lures
uh losers you'd have the builders land
landlords landlords investors and the
obvious winners but most homeowners are
going to end up being losers as their
neighborhoods are altered taxpayers are
going to definitely be the the biggest
losers because the small increase in
property taxes collected on those
properties are going to be dwarfed by
the huge increases in Education costs
and social service costs
it's been mentioned towns and cities
already can accomplish what this bill
tries to accomplish it's called zoning
regulations
and those regulations are the purview of
the municipalities they know their
infrastructure
infrastructure and citizens preferences
best we do not need Central planning
inspired legislation being forced upon
and mandated to these local communities
without regard to the fiscal and social
impact I'd ask that you join me in
pressing the red button so another
thank you Mr Speaker
I race in support of the majority
recommendation of ought to pass we have
been building we have been under
building homes in New Hampshire for
years and the short supply has driven
prices up at an accelerating rate
we need over 20 000 more homes in New
Hampshire to be at an equilibrium
do those twenty thousand homes on the
outskirts of towns requiring New Roads
and infrastructure make the most sense
or does fully utilizing the existing
infrastructure make more sense
this bill seeks to allow individuals who
want more homes in existing capacity on
existing infrastructure to be able to do
so
right now if a property owner wants to
propose a project which meets setbacks
height parking and other requirements of
the town but increases the units on the
lot to for the petty tyrants shove their
boot in the neck of the homeowners and
tell them no
unnecessary no's are the what got us in
this place and are that are what the
state of housing
um in the state of housing in New
Hampshire I asked you to join me in
supporting the individual property
rights of those citizens by removing the
petty tyrants
power to say no for no other reason that
they that they centrally planned that
the property be some other use than the
property owner wishes I ask you to join
me in protecting the rural communities
by encouraging the return to historic
neighborhoods to their intended use
instead of increasing pressure on
building on the outskirts of your town
for all these reasons and the ones
listed on the gold standard vote Yes on
this Bill thank you
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of water passes amended
on House Bill 44 a roll call has been
requested by representative turcotte and
in this officially seconded this is
going to be a roll call vote members
foreign
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of water Paso's amended
and House Pro 44. this is a roll call
vote
Jay I recognize representative turcott
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know the
municipalities already can implement the
zoning regulations suggested by this
bill without the heavy hand of
bureaucratic or political influence and
if I also know that forcing Central
planning inspired regulations will
create fiscal and social inequities
and finally Mr Speaker if I know that
mandating four units on residential lots
will end up creating unfunded mandates
on municipalities forced to upgrade
their water and sewer systems would I
now press the red button so another
motion can be made thank you Mr Speaker
I recognize representative Keller for a
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
infill in places served by water and
sewer spreads the cost for each mile of
that infrastructure over more people
people lowering the cost of the system
and taxes for each of those served and
letting the rest of New Hampshire be
more rural than they would otherwise be
as an alternative to building more
houses further and further into the
rural communities and if I know that the
state has the power to rein in decades
of rampant overzoning at the municipal
level and restore property rights to
provide desperately needed housing at
the discretion of the property owner and
if I know that the state should not
allow the representation of things the
state has allowed municipalities to
regulate to be captured by home owner
cronyism against the individual property
rights eroding those rights we are here
to protect would I now press the green
button and support the motion of ought
to pass as amended thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us the majority
committee report a lot of pastors
amended in Hillsboro 44. this is a roll
call vote you're in favor of your press
green button if you opposed to press a
red button voting stations are open for
for our members president had an
opportunity to vote I also attend the
117 148 232 voting a
majority committee report fails
Mr Speaker
for what reason does a member rise I
would like to make a motion to the table
and I'd like a division on that
the motion before us is the table house
a division has been requested members
the most the motion before us is to
table house bill 44.
it's a division vote
chair recognized represent vaginal for a
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that the housing crisis in the
state of New Hampshire is so bad
that the house set up a special
committee to deal with the problem
if I know that that committee would like
to have all available options
present in this fall
when we start looking at solutions to
this problem
and if I know that all of those things
are true
what I now
begrudgingly push the green button in
support of tabling
do you recognize the representative door
card for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know this bill
deserves another more appropriate motion
would I now vote no on the tabling
motion
the motion before us at the table house
bill 44. it's the vision vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
of your opposal press the red button the
[Music]
is it not working all right
members president had an opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
169 voting yay 181 voting a the tabling
okay I recognizes representative turcott
thank you Mr Speaker I make a motion of
the motion before us now is inexpedient
to legislate and house bill 44.
are you ready for the question
the vision has been requested
that's not showing up as
foreign
to legislate on House Bill 44.
this is going to be a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposer press the
red button voting stations are open for
foreign
[Music]
was present have an opportunity to vote
209 voting yay 141 voting a the motion
representative blows off declared a
conflict of interest and did not
committee on Municipal and County
government to which was referred House
Bill 123 relative to governing body
members of the budget committee
without recommendation it was in a lord
thank you Mr Speaker I Rise to speak
against house bill
123. the bill seeks to change the role
of the governing body representative and
the school board representative on local
budget committees
the issue that came forward to the
during the public hearings was that
during the formation of the warrant
articles the governing body and the
school board representative would never
vote to make any changes and that they
would work against the committee to try
to undermine the majority
current law actually deals with this
issue governing Bodies In addition to
having a school board excuse me budget
committees in addition to having a
governing body in the school board
representative have three to twelve
at-large members that are elected that
provide a majority of the budgeting
committee and provide oversight to
prevent exactly that problem
this bill seeks to go further by
stripping the school board and governing
body representative of their voting
rights it it drives a wedge between the
governing body the school board and the
budget committee and hinders the ability
of the many well-functioning budget
committees in sb2 communities across the
state that are able to craft well
thought through budgets that are passed
by their communities
this bill seeks to solve a problem by
creating many many more and should be
voted against inexpediate to legislate
thank you
thank you Mr Speaker uh honorable
colleagues so
this is a great bill and it's a needed
bill
we just heard that authoritative budget
committees are composed of three to 11
at large members
and an appointed member that's appointed
from the select board
and appointed member from the school
board
the fact of the matter is the school
board and the select board members have
already had
their bite at the Apple
and they've already had their vote
one person one vote
that is a pillar of American democracy
we accidentally got a little sidetracked
when it comes to authoritative budget
committees
so the select board member or the school
board member being appointed to
represent the will of the school board
or the select board
have to vote in accordance with what
those boards have already voted
a select board member can't show up at a
budget committee meeting
and vote contrary to what the board that
they came off of already voted because
they're there to represent the will of
that board
so if I have an elected at large budget
Committee of three people
and I have two that are appointed
it all but guarantees I have to have all
three votes to be able to carry it sets
the bar much much higher because the
appointed members
aren't free to act
but wait
it gets worse
so
pretend I'm the appointed School Board
member
how is it
that I vote
on Municipal questions
because I'm not a member of the select
board so I have no guidance I'm
appointed by the school board the school
board does not discuss does not take
positions on the municipal budget
and so they're voting
without representing their board because
they can't know the will of the board
vice versa for the select board member
so what happens in all practicality what
actually happens
is an unspoken quid pro quo
you support the school budget
I'll support the town budget
and vice versa
so now you've got these two lock step
votes but they've already voted you
already know their position because
they're members of those committees
so really those appointed members
should be advisory only
and it's the members that are elected to
the budget committee
the at-large members those are the
people that should be the voting members
now I've heard it said
they won't show up
they won't help
and you're going to be working in a
vacuum
there is no way
that a select board or a school board is
going to choose to not participate in
budget committee meetings because they
don't have a vote because it is still in
their best interest
to Advocate and defend for the budget
I can't imagine that a school board or a
select board would say you know what
screw it we're not going to send we're
not going to send a pardon my French I
apologize Mr Speaker that was a little
bit off color
we're not going to show up you know just
let them let them do what they want that
would never happen because it's in their
best interest to protect those budgets
this is a very simple change
to make budget committees a more
Equitable more properly representative
committee by allowing the the votes to
be made by the voting members only and
having the appointed members to Simply
Be advisory and for that reason I ask
you I implore you I beg you to support
the ought to pass motion thank you Mr
Speaker
representative Adrian and has requested
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
[Music]
the motion before us is ought to pass in
house bill 123. this is going to be a
roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that stripping a select board and
School Board representative votes on any
Amendment offered by a municipal budget
committee
to a municipal budget committee
operating budget as well as their votes
on the final Municipal budget committee
budget weakens the budget development
process
and Mr Speaker if I further know that
the select board and school board
members would not even count towards a
quorum of the committee
putting the posted meeting at risk of
failing to even have a quorum
and that will put the budget process at
risk then Mr Speaker would I oppose the
ought to pass motion so that another
motion can be made thank you
chair recognize representative Roy for a
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker and if I know that this isn't
about quorums this is about voting on
the budget that they already voted on
once already and if I know that we
created this law to give the taxpayers a
Fail-Safe a backstop to double check the
budget and if I further know that
allowing them to vote on it hinders that
we originally intended to do would I
vote to support this bill so that the
taxpayers truly have a second set of
eyes on the budget on their behalf thank
you
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 123. this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
four members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
168 voting yay 176.49 the motion fails
for what reason is memorized move to
table
motion to table is in proper order the
motion before us is the table house bill
123.
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
well supposedly
the eyes have it the eyes have it
members can stay in their seats
we have no debate in a roll call coming
up
the majority committee on Municipal and
County government to which was referred
House Bill 226 enact a neighboring
municipalities to regulate the
distribution and disposal of certain
Solid Waste within landfills considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate so Lori staff
is for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass as David preached for the minority
representative son in natashova's
requested a roll call and isn't
sufficiently seconded
members take your seats
here
the motion before us the majority
committed reported in expedient to
legislature in House Bill 226 this is a
roll call vote the chair recognizes
representative priests for a
Mr speaker thank you
if I know that numerous Studies have
shown that plastic production members
will be in this memorable member has to
be in his seats
use and Disposal are harmful to the
human health and the environment
and if I know that plastic pollution
crisis is impacting New Hampshire's
rivers lakes oceans and Wildlife
while retail and production businesses
have continued to fail to address this
growing crisis
and if I know that HB 266 is enabling
legislation not a mandate which allows a
local control to protect the health
welfare and safety of their residents
and to reduce the taxpayers cost in
mitigating the plastic pollution
would I now press the red button to
oppose the motion to itl hb266
so that municipalities are unable to
take action on their own and address
this proliferating problem
thank you I recognize representative
turquoise for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know this bill
was found in expedient to legislate in
committee by a very wide 16 to 4
bipartisan vote and if I know the
passage of this bill would create a
regulatory Nightmare and Patchwork of
unworkable and conflicting municipality
rules what I now press the green button
thank you Mr Speaker the motion before
us is the majority committee report of
index media to legislate on House Bill
226. this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
to be opposed or press the red button
foreign
wall members president had an
opportunity to vote household tend to
257 voting yay 190 voting a committee
majority of the committee on Municipal
and County government to which was
referred House Bill 312 not relative to
petitions for Warren articles at a
special meeting considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution we saw that as inexpedient to
legislate Senator Joshua Kellogg for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following Amendment the recommendation
that the bill had a password Amendment
on Lawrence levels for the minority of
for what reason to memorize
Mr Speaker I'd like to move to table
House Bill 312
and may I have a division
the motion is to table house bill
312 and this will be a division vote
foreign
the motion before us is the table House
Bill 312 this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative Weber for a
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the proponent of
the amendment that was sought has
decided to change his mind would I now
vote green on the tabling motion
the motion before us is the table House
Bill 312 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press a green
button of your opposer press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
foreign
was present had an opportunity to vote
316 voting a 30 voting a the tabling
committee on Municipal and County
government to which was referred House
Bill 357 relative to the length of terms
for Belknap County officers this comes
to us without recommendation chair
recognizes representative turcott
thank you Mr Speaker I have a motion
emotion is a proper motion
this is a division has been requested
Tim mcconaugh requested roll call is
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
foreign
the motion before us is the table house
bill 357. this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you opposed to press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
oh
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
177 voting yay 162 voting a tabling
majority of the committee on Municipal
and County government which was referred
Hospital 403 enact relativity authority
of Selectmen or assessors to Abate taxes
consider the same report the same with
the following resolution it resolved
that is inexpeding to legislate Senator
Lori status for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following Amendment and recommendation
to pay law to pass with Amendment
Senator Lynn turcott for the minority of
the committee
chair recognizes representative
thank you Mr Speaker my name is
representative Jonathan Smith I
represent the great people of Ossipee
and Carroll County District 5.
I consider HB 403 relative to the
authority of Selectmen or assessors to
I am the chair of the Ossipee select
board
recently we had a tax exemption case go
before the Bureau of tax and land
appeals better known as btla
during this hearing the subject matter
change from tax exemptions to good cause
abatements currently selectman or
assessors May obey taxes for good cause
if I polled all 400 representatives in
this chamber to Define good cause I
guarantee I would never get the same
answer twice
good cause is ambiguous how can we as
Representatives expect our local elected
officials to make sound decisions based
on such ambiguous guidance
this ambiguity leads to corruption and
nepotism there are two btla court cases
that show how good cause abatements were
abused and overturned they were in
Seabrook docket number
26624-120s and Berlin docket number
259-285-190s
in the court documents for the Berlin
case this corruption was on full display
when the dra stated that the facts
demonstrate inequity and self-dealing on
the part of the board of assessors just
think about that inequity and
self-dealing
during the town of ossipee's btla
hearing department of revenue Chief
assessor Philip Bodwell gave the dra
definition of good cause to mean
assessment or evaluation errors and
hardship
the btla agrees with this definition my
bill expands Upon A dra definition to
include administrative and clerical
errors and poverty
poverty replaces the hardship definition
because it can be clearly defined using
federal poverty guidelines as stated in
the bill
this bill does not tie the hands of
elected officials as some would say
actually it gives elected officials and
assessors freedom to make sound decisive
and fair decisions that will keep
personal opinions bias and nepotism from
the decision to Abate taxes
this bill brings transparency
accountability and a government that
works for all the people
let me ask every member of this chamber
a part in question why would I as the
chair of my town select board create a
bill that would undermine the ability or
the authority of the board on which I
serve
I ask you to press the red button so
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker HP 403 seeks to make a
seemingly innocuous change in the
wording of RSA 7616
this is the law that grants authority to
select board members and assessors to
Abate residential taxes
a casual reading of that change that
this bill proposes might lead you to
believe that there's nothing major at
stake here it's just housekeeping
you might look at the notion of
substituting administrative or clerical
errors for these existing laws term good
cause shown as inconsequential maybe
even a good idea
but good cause isn't just any term it
has legal heft
it can be used in a courtroom to prove a
sufficient reason for a ruling or an
action by a judge in fact it's often
used to place the burden on the litigant
to show why exactly a request should be
refused or granted
in the case of RSA 76 the term good
cause does exactly that
it places the burden on the select board
and assessors to demonstrate objective
evidence that the original assessment
was incorrect
during our hearing of HB 403 we could we
couldn't quite nail down exactly what
might constitute an administrative or
clerical error we were left to conclude
this was not such an innocuous or
housekeeping change in language after
all what the bill really proposes is
removing the legal authority to Grant
abatements from those in whom such
Authority is vested
we thought this to be unwise we believed
the drafters of the existing law were
onto something and that something
probably shouldn't be changed I urge you
to support the committee's
recommendation of inexpedient to
the motion before us
is the majority committee report of in
expedient to legislator and house bill
403.
the vision has been requested members
foreign
the motion before us is the majority
committed report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 403.
this is going to be a division vote
chair recognized representative Jonathan
if I know that good cause is ambiguous
and that the dra and btla have defined
good cause if I know that this bill
defines good cause more broadly than the
ptla and dra by including poverty if I
know that this bill will bring
transparency accountability to the
decision to obey taxes which should
never be used as tools for favors and
self-dealing would I now press the red
button so another motion can be made
thank you
chair recognize representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair
if I know this bill does not define
administrative or clerical errors or has
anything different than for good cause
if I know that administrative and
clerical errors are already reasons for
a good cause for abatements and if I
know that as a select board member for
over 16 years I have put my signature to
abatements for good cause
of these limitations and Beyond
I would would I then press the green
button to vote HB 403 in expedient to
legislate
the motion before us a majority
committee report of index Beauty to
legislator and House Bill 403 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button of your opposed
or press a red button voting stations
yes
questions
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to stay to the
vote
200 voting a 144 voting a committee
Mr Speaker
four reason memorize I Rise for a motion
stage motion Mr Speaker I moved to
remove uh House Bill 234 relative to
renewable energy tax credits from the
table
fish
ing food
energy
foreign
okay members take your seats
the motion before us is to move remove
House Bill 234 from the table
this is going to be a division vote
chair recognizes representative Weber
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
it's a member who would like to
reconsider their votes on House Bill 234
relative to renewable energy tax credits
what I now press the green button to
chair recognizes representative votes
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that we had a healthy debate about
this bill about two weeks ago
and if I know that we're laid it on the
table for good cause and good reason
and if I further know this bill if it's
removed from the table will increase
electricity costs for everybody in our
state when I press the red button to
leave this bill on the table thank you
the motion before us to remove House
Bill 234 from the table this is a
division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
foreign
if Allman was president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
also be in order
majority of the committee on resources
Recreation development to which was
referred House Bill 310 the ACT
requiring developers to secure hydrology
and analyst certifying adequate water
capacity and portability when building
new subdivisions having considered the
same report the same with the falling
resolution resolved that is inexpeding
to legislators Robert Healey for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass Senator Rosemary rung for the
minority of the committee
the question before us is the motion to
in expedient to legislate on House Bill
310. are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
those opposed May
you guys have it and the committee
committee on state and federal relations
and Veterans Affairs the which was
referred hcr1 enact a resolution
applying for a Convention of the states
under Article 5 of The Constitution of
the United States have been considered
the same report this same with the
recommendation of Bill ought to pass
it's on a brand Infinity for the
committee
chair recognizes
the house will be in order
thank you very much Mr Speaker I'll uh I
think there's eight more votes between
us and lunch so hopefully I'll try to
keep it brief and I rise in opposition
to hcr1 a resolution applying for a
Convention of the states under Article 5
of the constant
States and I'm
I'm concerned that any Article Five
constitution convention could easily
turn to The Runaway convention and the
way HDR is written this one
is probably almost guaranteed to turn to
Runaway uh convention the first two
items are so vague
and so far-reaching as you pretty much
guarantee if a runaway convention and
it's really unclear why such a
convention is even necessary I'm
certainly not saying the federal
government is perfect but
it's already under quote fiscal
constraints unquote and I don't even
really know exactly what that term means
but obviously it has a limited amount of
money even though it's fast but limited
and the power and jurisdiction the
federal government has already limited
the third topic is term limits and
I know that's a fashionable idea in some
circles where we the people have been
rejecting the idea of congressional term
limits every election cycle every two
years when we democratically re-elect
congresspersons and Senators who have
been serving for a long time more than
and uh as I said it's far from perfect
but it's not totally out of control I
think it still operates within the
bounds of the United States Constitution
and
I spent the last 15 years of my life in
state government I love all three
branches in my state government but the
federal government is not necessarily uh
more regressive less responsive or more
oppressive than the state governments
usually allowed the not in our state so
much but actually a lot of the worst um
the worst offenses against Liberty
actually take place at the state level
uh even more so than at the federal
level and um
I'm I'm going first and uh so nobody has
talked about the debt so I won't go into
too much detail except to say that uh
the idea that debt the federal
government is actually having uh
no trouble uh selling dead instruments
only about a tenth of the figure you see
is actually debt that's over by the
federal government to entities other
than the government uh
about uh
about 70 percent of it is the money
supply and uh sure we have uh the Euro
crypto we have a bunch of other
currencies but the US dollar is still
the world's
Reserve currency is still the strongest
currency in the world about 70 percent
of that is our money supply and also a
lot of it is also
debt when Federal agency owes to another
Federal agency so it's actually about
one-tenth the figure you see and it's uh
you know
if there's any consolation
we're a debt creditor to the rest of the
world so they owe us uh the rest of the
world owes the United States about 13
trillion dollars so we're actually like
making out on the deal so
so in any case this uh resolution is
unnecessary and I urge you to uh
thank you Mr Speaker
thank you for your time and your
patience today
Article 5 of the U.S Constitution reads
in part
the Congress whenever two-thirds of both
houses shall deem it necessary shall
propose amendments to this constitution
or on the application of the
legislatures of two-thirds of the
several States shall call a convention
for proposing amendments
the application for a Convention of
states is important for specific
amendments that impose fiscal restraints
on the federal government
to limit the power and the jurisdiction
of the federal government and to limit
the terms of office for members of
Congress
this committee agrees that Congress has
neglected their duties and ignored the
United States Congress has usurped
states rights
they've driven up the national debt with
Reckless monetary policy
and corruption with campaign funding and
electoral Monopoly
in order to maintain the checks and
balances outlined in the Constitution
the states must call a Convention of
states to propose these specific
amendments
let me be very clear right now
in Article 5 convention is not a
constitutional convention that has been
misrepresented over and over again
through the years that our committee has
heard this issue
an article 5 convention is only to
propose amendments only amendments to
the Constitution it is not to rewrite
the Constitution to remake it to remold
it to do anything
other than to propose amendments for
there is no such thing as a runaway
convention
it is a myth
perpetuated by people that don't
member will suspend it's getting awful
loud in here if you want to have a
conversation take it out into the Annie
room thank you member may continue thank
you
we have a duty
to Future generations to protect their
rights
to protect the Integrity of our economy
and elections and to rebalance state
federal power
an article 5 convention is the safest
non-violent and bipartisan way to reform
the government to use the Constitution
that we are all sworn to protect and to
as of today
39 states have passed a valid
application for a convention for fiscal
responsibility alone
while 19 States total have passed
applications for for a convention to
propose all three amendments
we can be the the 20th State
to tell our federal Congress that they
suck
it is all right that's that's
over 400 applications since 1788 400
applications for a Convention of states
have been passed
since 1789 Congress has proposed 12 000
amendments
33 proposed amendments to the state's
ratification have been sent but only 27
have been ratified by
by the required uh percentage of states
to prevent future corporatism and
plutocracy that is infesting our country
currently a Convention of states is the
to reform the government to make it work
for the people again and to force
Congress to stop ignoring us
and the only reason I'm so
aggressive about this issue is because
we are 32 trillion dollars in debt
I don't know if anyone understands how
a Psalms Duty
as a legislature
as a governing body
to send a message to Congress that we're
not playing around anymore
Congress has ignored us ignored the
people
and driven our country into the
extremism and political apathy that we
see today something has to give and
something has to change
we can be a part of that change
if we're brave enough
to vote in favor of the ought to pass
for hcr1
for only the application for a
Convention of states to utilize the
power that the founders gave us who had
the foresight to understand as societal
cultural and technological Evolution
will happen in our society and the only
way that that we can change it is to use
the Constitution that we're all sworn to
protect please vote in favor of hcr1
today thank you
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if
there's one thing I have learned in 19
years in this house
is then when you're speaking on one of
the last Bills on the calendar and the
second day of the session in the middle
of winter be brief and I will
Mr Speaker there's a lot of questions
and concerns about the bill before the
uh house Resolute house concurrent
resolution before us
first of all in the history of our
nation there's only been one Article 5
convention that was in 1787.
this would be the second if was accepted
since that time
there have been 27 Amendments passed to
our constitution including to us
probably the most important 10
the first in our Bill of Rights
Mr Speaker
as I mentioned there are questions
concerns
in confusion dealing with this bill
it's the groups
that have come together in opposition to
the premise of an article 5 convention
when you have the AFL-CIO
and you have the John Burke Society
and when you have
common cause
NAACP the League of Women Voters the
Brennan says Center for justice when you
have
the Sierra Club
all uniting on one purpose to stop the
unnecessary need of an article five
convention concerned about questions
about where the money is coming from the
supporting this movement and for those
that have concerns about what an article
5 convention could do to some of the
most important amendments in our
constitution as they stand today I would
ask this chamber to please vote red so
another motion could be made and thank
you Mr Speaker
chair recognized representative Dan
Maguire
thank you Mr Speaker
have you ever wondered why you're paid
200 for this session
the answer is it's due to the great
railroad Scandal of 1887 and the
outrageous spending that was taking
place in this room
and as a consequence the people put
together a convention to propose the
amendment to the to our Constitution
that sets our salary
but I'll go into more detail in a minute
but before I get to that let's motivate
um hcr1
so we've heard about the tremendous debt
of the federal government 30 something
trillion dollars but I want to I want to
put that into context
one out of every 250 people in the
United States lives in New Hampshire
that makes our share of that trillion 30
trillion dollars about 125 billion
dollars
and if you look at the total value of
all real property in New Hampshire all
commercial property all residential
property that's also about 125 billion
dollars
so if we need wanted to pay back our
part of this debt
that would be like adding a new mortgage
a new second mortgage on every property
owner in the state commercial and
residential
with no down payment starting at zero
right that's what we have to do to pay
back that debt that that doesn't include
unfunded liabilities so add another
mortgage for Social Security at another
mortgage for other unfunded liabilities
and you can see how outrageous their
now I don't really blame the people in
Congress
um for this debt it's it's we sought
ourselves yesterday
when we passed spending bill after
spending bill
but we are limited by reality
you know the money tree that the Ways
and Means Committee keeps locked in
their closet only has so many leaves on
it
so you know we can pass as many spending
bills as you want but at the end of the
day the amount we are actually going to
spend is limited right but in Washington
they've discovered that there are no
limits
right they they can create dollars and
they can spend and that's where
inflation comes from
okay
so the only way we can limit them is via
the Constitution that's the purpose of a
constitution is to put limits on
government and our U.S Constitution is
relatively silent about spending it has
some stuff about money mostly about how
to turn metal into coins and stuff like
that right but but it re the only thing
it talks about with spending is the 10th
Amendment which says if we didn't give
you a specific okay to do something you
can't do it right well that turned out
to be too vague to be enforceable
all right so we need to put some limits
on Congress and their fiscal
um outrageousness and this is our way of
doing it because we can't we can't
Congress it's unreasonable to expect
Congress to put in a constitutional
amendment to restrict their own power
right we wouldn't do that to ourselves
so when when the people wanted to
restrict our salaries they had to do it
themselves they had to put in their own
Constitutional Amendment and pass it
themselves and that's what happened to
us so in 1887
there was
um at the time this was this is at the
time when that clock was still under
um they were the representatives in this
room 307 of them were paid three dollars
a day per diem
so at the time the average salary in New
Hampshire was 14 cents an hour
okay today the average salary is 25 an
hour so that three dollars per diem is
like 500 a day
that's how much they were paid okay and
they met starting in June June 1st
because notice that this was part of the
building uh first of all it's it's was
unheated at the time but it also has no
bathrooms
right all the bathrooms are in the 1910
section over there right so so we're
talking outhouses and
um so at the time they were paying paid
three dollars a day and they had this
giant Scandal dealing with railroads and
bills and so on and they stayed in
session and paid themselves for 158 days
straight June 1st to November 5th
so they paid themselves including
weekends even though they were here
three or four days a week so that was so
outrageous that 474 dollars each was so
outrageous that the people put a stop to
it
and look at what they gave us right that
simple thing and by the way they also
moved the session to January at the same
time right so they they reduced our
salary made us meet in the winter so we
would get through quicker all right all
right so
um and look at what that gave us that
gave us this fantastic legislature this
volunteer legislature you know over time
over those hundred and some years
we have this fantastic legislature I
would pit the life experience in this
room against any other such room in the
country including the Congress
all right so this is our way
of doing something right
for the United States for the for our
spending for our fiscal restraints so
please join me in pushing the green
button to pass this resolution thank you
Mr Speaker
the motion before us is the underpass
don't representative Lakers request the
roll calls that's officially seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
[Music]
foreign
thanks
members take your seats this is going to
the motion before us is ought to pass on
hcr1
this will be a roll call vote the chair
recognized representative Kerry for a
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know our United States Constitution
has been amended 27 times without an
article 5 convention
and if I know there are many passionate
people
who are concerned about term limits and
spending limits but they also know that
those people as I do have the ability
and the right and the responsibility to
affect change by exercising their
constitutional right to vote
and furthermore do I know that in New
Hampshire we have a long tradition of it
ain't broke don't fix it will I please
now press the red button
so that we do not change our beloved
United States Constitution thank you Mr
Speaker
also be in order
chair recognize representative moffatt
thank you Mr Speaker
uh I anticipated a uh a friend from the
side who's going to give this Pi but
I'll simply say that if this body would
simply trust the bipartisan majority of
this this is a parliamentary inquiry Mr
Speaker
yes Mr Speaker the uh the individual who
signed up to the pi I can see from this
apologies
foreign
I'll defer to the gentlelady
I recognize representative Massimo for a
thank you Mr Speaker
honorable colleagues
if I know the founding fathers in their
wisdom allowed the creation of
amendments for improving the
Constitution
and they also understood the effects of
power and authority on human nature
if I also believe that article 5
was given to us as a system of checks
and balances
to use when Congress refuses to act on
the concerns of We the People
and finally
if I know that both faith and fear ask
us to believe in something that we
cannot see
and leaves the choice up to us
and if I'm certain that the founding
fathers had faith that future
Generations would use an article 5
wisely
and only when necessary
would you now join me in choosing faith
in the process that the founding fathers
left We the People
and press the green button to support
the bipartisan committee recommendation
of ought to pass
thank you
the motion before us is ought to pass on
hcr1 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
of your opposal press the red button
questions
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will tend to state of the
vote
156 voting yay 192 voting day the motion
fails
I Rise to make a Motion state of motion
I moved that HCI 1bitlt
it has for most promotion the motion is
to an expedient to legislate in HCR one
for what reason does a member rise to
make a motion
State your motion I move to table hcr1
it is a higher motion so the motion
before us is the table hcr1
a division has been requested
the motion before us is the table hcr1
this is going to be a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
Charlotte for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that HCR one has been well vetted
and not committed and that we've all
received much information about this
issue but Mr Speaker if I feel that hcl1
is not right for the people of the
Granite State
what I now push the red button to defeat
the motion to table so another motion
oh yeah the chair recognizes
representative hole for a parliamentary
if I know that our national debt is now
over 30 trillion dollars
given the 330 million Americans that's
almost a hundred thousand dollars per
person in national debt
if I further know that Congress isn't
listening to us
and that's said on both sides of the
aisle
that's not a a republican thing or a
Democrat thing there are people across
the Spectrum who believe that is what's
in happening in Congress is broken
if I further know that we had a good
debate and the committee recommended
ought to pass but that was not decided
today what I now support a cabling
motion and press the green button so
that this bill could be worked on and
addressed later thank you motion before
us is table hcr1
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press a green button to
your pulse or press the right button
foreign
members president had an opportunity to
163 voting a 184 voting nay
the motion tabling motion fails
we're now we're now back to the motion
of inexpeding to legislate
huh
who
thank you
the motion before us is inexpected to
legislate an hcr1 this is a division
vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposer press the
red button voting stations are open for
foreign
members president had an opportunity to
198 voting yay 150 voting a
today
the majority of the committee on state
federal relations and Veterans Affairs
to which was referred house resolution
eight and acts urging Congress to enact
legislation regulating and banning
certain semi-automatic assault weapons
and large capacity ammunition feeding
devices
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislative representative Tom mannion
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation at the bill Archer pass
Representative Steve shurtleff for the
the member from Keene representative
toll is recognized to speak against the
honorable colleagues my name is Amanda
Elizabeth toll and I'm here today to
speak in strong support of hr8
urging Congress to ban assault weapons
and large capacity magazines
school shootings and gun violence on
this level are a uniquely American
epidemic
stay 12 children die as a result of a
gun another 32 are injured
since the tragic Columbine massacre in
1999 there have been well over 300
school shootings guns are the leading
cause of death among American children
and teens
large capacity magazines result in 14
times as many people being killed or
wounded during a shooting event and
between 2009 and 2018
59 percent of mass shootings involved
high-capacity magazines
Banning assault rifles and large
capacity magazines is common sense
ending ownership of these weapons of
mass destruction should not be an issue
of political ideology there is no valid
moral or ethical stance that can support
the right of someone to own a gun that
can kill many school children in the
blink of an eye it is our moral calling
to put an end to the senseless Slaughter
of the innocent and protect our children
I'll say that one more time it is our
moral calling to put an end to the
senseless Slaughter of the innocent and
protect our children
Common Sense gun control measures such
as these are proven effective Research
indicates that in states with
restrictions on magazine size mass
shootings occur at less than half the
rates of states without restrictions
in New Zealand in 2019 a gunman entered
two mosques and killed 51 people
injuring 40 more seven days later New
Zealand instituted a national ban on all
semi-automatic weapons and later on all
assault rifles and parts just one
massacre in New Zealand changed their
gun laws here in the United States we
have let massacres happen over and over
again with no action but we can change
that no one needs access to large
capacity magazines or Weaponry that can
take out dozens of people within a few
moments these are weapons that bring
only the mass murder of Americans we can
put an end to such horrific and needless
Bloodshed with common sense gun control
laws we can stand up to the gun
lobbyists and say enough is enough and
protect our neighbors and our children
from Slaughter as a mother I stand in
solidarity with mothers around the
nation demanding action and today you
have an opportunity to stand in
solidarity with us by supporting hr8
urging Congress to ban assault weapons
and large capacity feeding devices I
this will be in order there's a member
the member will suspended
the member from Pelham representative
Manion is recognized to speak in support
the committee report of itl on HRA
the 20th century is filled with millions
of reasons to never permit a government
to restrict your natural right of
self-defense Pol Pot 2 million Adolf
Hitler 13 million Joseph Stalin 20
million Mao Zedong 45 million these are
the lowball estimates of civilians
massacred after private firearm
ownership was banned by those leaders
contrary to what the president May
repeat in front of the cameras our
natural right to keep and bear arms is
not so we can go deer hunting or sport
shooting it is to prevent the
that have played out by Fascist
governments
supporters of the federal assault
weapons ban will Echo the refrain that
the founders could not have imagined
modern Firearms but cannons existed
privateer's own Battleship equivalents
of the day
the founders were fully aware of the
evolution of arms and that is evident by
the use of that specific word arms in
the Second Amendment not just muskets
not just Swords not just pistols no such
limitation is defined
in Congress last session H.R 1808 was
the proposed assault weapon ban of 2022.
the bill swept so broadly that it would
have made millions of owned firearms
illegal overnight also including several
hunting rifle and shotgun models
during the hearing Congressman Dan
Bishop asked would anyone on the other
side dispute that this bill would ban
weapons that are in common use in the
U.S today
chairman Jerry Nadler replied that's the
point of the bill
this flies directly in the face of dcv
Heller where the Supreme Court held that
arms in common use
we're protected under the Second
Amendment
this alone makes any bans
unconstitutional based on President H.R
1808 also Exempted all Departments of
the federal government from the ban
all departments Congressman Thomas
Massey attempted to amend the build
clarifying that of course this wouldn't
include the Departments of education and
agriculture
since the bill supporters keep referring
to AR-15s as weapons of war and only
useful for mass murder why would
Department of teachers or Farmers need
this when answering this very question
the bill supporter said because they may
need to defend themselves
okay so they aren't only useful for mass
murder or just war and apparently the
rest of our lives aren't important
enough to let us defend ourselves in the
same manner
this type of Monopoly of force is
precisely the outcome the founders
wanted to prevent by including the
Second Amendment which I will add
doesn't grant us any right we are born
with the natural right of self-defense
to protect ourselves our families our
property the Second Amendment along with
the entire Bill of Rights is a list of
restrictions on the federal government
to protect our natural rights and
Liberty
support Liberty and tyranny vote itl on
representative Stanton Nostalgia request
a roll call vote which is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
foreign
together
the question before the house is the
majority committee report of inexped
against the legislate on house
resolution 8. this is a roll call vote
representative O'Neill is recognized for
regardless of part of parties or which
side of this room we're sitting on today
wish to keep our families safe
and if I know that policies such as this
one encourage and support responsible
gun ownership
are proven to reduce fatalities and
injuries caused by mass shootings events
and ultimately protect our children not
just for mass shootings but also from
the traumatic and very real fear that
these kids face each time they walk into
a school building what I now vote know
representative Manion is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
CDC reported A Renewed assault weapon
ban would have no measurable different
difference on gun violence and if I know
any Bill Banning firearms and common
usage violates Heller Vs DC ruling and
if I know that Columbine occurred during
the last Federal assault weapons ban and
if I further know that we only have to
look at the last century to see the
disastrous outcome of governments having
Monopoly ownership over firearms and Mr
Speaker finally if I know the definition
of shall not be infringed I would press
the question is on the majority
committee report of an expedient to
legislate this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
foreign
of all members present and an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
181 in the affirmative 162 and the
for this one there's no debate that
there is a division
might as well stay in your seats there's
no debate and this is a division vote on
the next one
the committee on state federal relations
and Veterans Affairs to which is
referred house resolution 9 an act
calling for the federal government to
enact an American Marshall plan to
rebuild economically impoverished
communities and strengthen climate
resilience infrastructure having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that it
is inexped into legislative
representative Moffett requests a
division vote this will be a division
the question is on the
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on house resolution 9.
representative Madison Miller is
thank you Mr Speaker
honorable colleagues if I know that
President Harry Truman and secretary
George Marshall had the wisdom in
foresight after the second world war to
know that economic desperation is a
breeding ground for authoritarianism
and if I know that the original Marshall
Plan put a devastated Europe back on its
feet and likely saved the world from
plunging into chaos for a third time
and if I believe that those same
feelings of desperation exist in many
American communities today such as the
flooded Kentucky Hills the shells of
factories in Michigan and the bone dry
former lakes in Utah
and lastly if I know that the
preservation of democracy requires a
belief in the future for subsequent
Generations would I not push the red
button to overturn the Ito and send a
message to Washington that it's time for
a martial like plan for the United
representative Mendon is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
before in history with large portions of
that money being misappropriated or
going unaccounted for and if I know that
a project of this size would undoubtedly
inject trillions more into the 32.5
trillion national debt a debt of jet a
debt to GDP ratio of 120 percent and if
I know that the inflation reduction act
added positions for 87 000 IRS agents to
squeeze taxes from us to compensate
Unstoppable federal spending and if I
further know that we are experiencing
rapid inflation due to these federal
spending sprees and that inflation is
the one of the most Insidious taxes and
finally Mr Speaker if I know that
taxation is theft then I would press the
green button and itl hr9 the house will
really this is how we're going to end
the questions on the committee report of
an expediential legislate if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
Specializes
[Music]
representative allenser caught
please
of all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
176 in the affirmative 169 and negative
the committee on state federal relations
and Veterans for what reason does a
well
yeah
I have been my uh by oath to the
my grievance is I I sworn over that I
would protect the Constitution
and the Constitution says that taxation
is one of our duties and a member said
that
that feels that
is
users remember abuses me is not her
Focus
message
yourself
foreign
the committee on state federal relations
and Veterans Affairs to which is
referred house resolution 10 an act
supporting statehood for the District of
Columbia having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is inexped
into legislative representative Tony
piamante for the committee
the member from Penacook representative
shurtleff is recognized to speak against
thank you Mr Speaker representative
Schultz is the prime sponsor on this
bill and unfortunately she is not with
us today so I will speak in support of
the bill in support of uh overturning
the ietl and believe me I will be brief
um
Mr Speaker this is a bill that came
before us to Grant to send a house
resolution to Washington asking the
District of Columbia be granted
statehood
and um I would say to you a couple of
things about the district first of all
the residents of the District of
Columbia
have every responsibility you and I have
as American citizens
they serve our country in time of peace
and War they pay their federal taxes and
they contribute in so many other ways
however
they don't get to elect the president
they have won person that represents
them in Congress and without the full
voting Powers as a member of Congress
lastly next to the last thing Washington
DC has a population of 700 plus thousand
people
which makes it almost 200 000 people
more than the state of Wyoming but yet
again they have no full rights as
American citizens
and I think it's almost
I'm trying to say this delicately as
some of us may have learned over the
past few years it may be important for
Washington the District of Columbia to
be a state and to have a governor
instead of a mayor and I would ask you
to vote red on the itl so another motion
could be brought forward thank you Mr
Speaker
the member from Loudoun representative
Moffat is recognized speak in support of
thank you Mr Speaker
I fed the occasion to spend a lot of
time in DCS to be stationed down that
way
among other reasons and I've noticed as
probably many of you have you know folks
here by our license plate which is
famous they have a famous license plate
out of DC
uh it says taxation without
representation and I get that
but
even though 90 percent of the voters
down there in D.C
vote with the other party
they apparently agree with many of the
folks on on the red side of the house of
this chamber that get ready for it
so for something this important
this should be bipartisan support
but this is a very partisan proposal
the party for which 90 of the D.C
residents vote of course they want D.C
statehood the party for which 10 percent
of the D.C residents vote see it
otherwise
in D.C statehood would likely be
unconstitutional Article 1 Section 8 of
The Constitution does say that Congress
should be in charge of the seat of
government
which will be quote from the
Constitution
District not exceeding 10 miles Square
so this resolution favors something that
apparently is unconstitutional
we should concern anyone who
follows the Constitution
so the Constitution they think should
outweigh politics and something as
important as this now one remedy that
has been suggested that makes sense to
me and others was shared with me by a
very prominent member of this house very
prominent member I won't say who it was
from our committee but I thought his uh
thought to me was made a lot of sense
simply shrink the federal district down
to the core of Washington
where the capital and the Supreme Court
and the White House and the monuments
and the government buildings are there's
your federal district and then uh the
residential districts of uh DC would
revert to Maryland
to whom it once belonged
uh Maryland would probably gain one
congressional seat that's fine it's a
better solution than creating a new
state
if the federal district became a part of
a new state think about what happened
then what kind of benefits did that new
state of DC get the new state of DC I
think would do pretty well with the the
federal government as compared to say
the state of New Hampshire
so
uh
Washington's NFL franchise is actually
in Maryland
and if the D.C football team
can still be called Washington while
playing in Maryland I think the rest of
DC could also
survive that and the pirate the southern
part of the original District included
the northern part of Virginia and that
that's happened the northern part of
Virginia which was part of D.C
Alexandria in 1846 became part of
Virginia so there was a president for
for that approach so I would simply ask
that you please please support the
committee's itl recommendation on HR 10.
the question is on the committee report
of inexperienced legislative are you
ready for the question
division has been requested this will be
foreign the question is on the committee
report of an expedient to legislate on
house resolution 10. this is a division
vote
representative Seibert is recognized for
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that currently the
federal government has significant
control over DC's local Affairs
including its budget and laws
and if I know that statehood would Grant
DC greater autonomy to govern itself
allowing residents to have more control
over the decisions that affect their
daily lives and if I know a majority of
D.C residents support statehood and
several National polls have also shown
majority support among Americans for D.C
to become a state
then would I press the red button to
vote against the committee report of Ito
representative moffats recognized for
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that DC does have three
electoral votes
and if I also know that the HR 10
resolution supports an unconstitutional
Ultra partisan scheme where they then
press the green button to support the
the question is on the majority
committee report of inexperience a
legislative this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button opposed press the red button
wow
[Music]
foreign
had an opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
179 in the affirmative 168 and the
Mr Speaker for what reason does remember
us for a motion Mr Speaker
foreign
I'm sorry what for a motion State
emotion please
[Music]
I moved to remove House Bill 430
relative to education Freedom accounts
foreign
Weber moves that house bill 430 be
removed from the table this will be a
everybody
the question is whether to remove House
Bill 430 from the table representative
Weber is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
speaker knowing that it is against our
rules to debate the underlying bill
could I just say that if I knew that a
member wants to change their vote on an
earlier vote would I vote to remove
representative Cordell is recognized for
parliamentary incorrect thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that I do not want to
change my vote and if I know that the
intent of this bill is to drastically
alter the successful education Freedom
accounts what I now vote to
what I now vote to leave this bill on
the table
and press
the question is whether to lay House
Bill 430 on the table
to remove House Bill 430 from the table
if you're in favor of removing you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
thank you
[Music]
I'm all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
thou shall attended the state of the
vote
177 in the affirmative 169 and the
negative
excuse me
did
adjustment
s
because
foreign
all right so the pending question is in
expedient to legislate on House Bill
430.
foreign
questions
right so this will be a division yeah
this will be a division vote on inexped
into legislate members please take your
seats
who requested
representative Ammon is requesting a the
house will be in order representative
Ammons requesting a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
foreign
all right
this is a roll call vote
on an expedient to legislate on House
Bill 430. representative luno is
thank you very much Mr Speaker if I know
that back on February 14th
House Bill 430 was had a tie vote in the
uh on the motion of ought to pass with
the presiding officer breaking uh making
that tie and if I know that there is a
member in this chamber who
who voted against the OTP who would now
like to change their vote and if I know
that of the nearly 25 million dollars in
taxpayer money that's been spent in the
first two years of the EFA program uh
went to went to pay private school
tuition and homeschooling costs for more
than 80 percent of of homeschoolers and
if I know that uh that the Department of
Education is requesting another 60
million dollars in taxpayer money to be
to be spent again with the vast majority
of that to pay exist tuition bills for
existing private school and home school
students would I vote no and press the
red button against the itl motion so uh
so another motion could be reconsidered
thank you
representative Lads recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you very
much Mr Speaker if I know this bill
would eliminate the opportunity for a
student that's moving into the state to
attend to receive an EFA seeing the bill
requires they be in public school for at
least one year
if I know this is another challenge to
disrupt our program of providing choice
and the best fit for children in this
state when I vote then the act and press
the button to green button to support
the question is inexpeding to legislate
on House Bill 430 and this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button opposed press the
red button voting stations are open for
foreign
members present had an opportunity to
vote the house will attended the state
170 in the affirmative 175 in the
negative the motion fails
Representatives Hicks and seaworth
declared conflicts and did not
participate
for what reason does it remember us
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker having voted on the
prevailing side
and knowing that I made a mistake by
misreading
the intent of the emotion
and blaming my third grade reading
I moved to reconsider the motion of
for what reason does a member rise
parliamentary inquiry Mr Speaker go
ahead uh my understanding was that the
vote was on itl and there was no vote on
OTP
thank you correct
and for what reason does this member
rise thank you Mr Speaker question of
the chair or the speaker sure
um would you please explain to the
audience the motion of reconsideration I
thought there was a time limit on the
reconsideration motion
not when the bill is here before us and
okay
the motion is whether to reconsider
house bill 430.
the
the question is whether to reconsider
House Bill 430 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
yeah
ball members present had an opportunity
to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
176 in the affirmative 169 and the
now we're at the Archer pass motion for
right
for what reason does remember us
Mr Speaker I move that we and definitely
okay the motion is indefinitely
postponed and this is a division vote
the motion is whether to indefinitely
postpone house bill 430. this is a
division vote if you're in favor you
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
foreign
[Music]
members present had an opportunity to
vote
the house will attended the state of the
169 in the affirmative 176 and the
negative the motion fails
we're back to ought to pass
on House Bill 430 and let's do another
okay
this is a division vote
the motion is ought to pass on House
Bill 430. representative cordelli is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that the EFA program is
successful
and I know that kids who are
striving for better education options
are now being served
if I know that there are those who say
it's all for the kids
don't really mean it
if I know that
if I know that this program needs to be
needs to be defended and expanded to
help kids in this state who are
struggling what I now
representative lunos recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you very much Mr Speaker if I know
that all these public taxpayer dollars
just about all of these public taxpayer
dollars just about 90 million in public
taxpayer dollars are going to pay
private school tuition bills then
wouldn't I vote vote push the green
button vote Yes on the the motion of OTP
the motion is ought to pass on House
Bill 430. this is a division boot if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
foreign
[Music]
Phillips
as a have all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attendant of the state of
the vote
176 in the affirmative
176 in the affirmative 169 and the
negative
the motion of us to pass passes
Representatives Hicks and seaworth
declare conflicts and did not
participate in House Bill 430 is
the committee on the committee on state
federal relations and Veterans Affairs
to which was referred house resolution
15 an act relative to affirming support
against the establishment of a state
religion having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislative
representative Michael moffatt for the
committee the question is on the
committee report of inexperience to
legislate are you ready for the question
the eyes have it and the committee
foreign
the motion is to remove House Bill 234
from the table and this is a division
clear
the question is whether to remove House
Bill 234 from the table
representative Weber's recognized for
speak without making any reference to
the substance of the sense of underlying
debating the underlying Bill
if I know that a member wishes to change
you think this is House of Commons stop
it
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that a
member wishes to change his vote would I
now vote green on the motion to remove
from the table
representative votes is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know of no one who wants to change their
vote on this issue
and if I know that we put this bill on
the table because we couldn't come to
any kind of decision about it
when I press the red button to leave it
on the table thank you
the question is whether to remove House
Bill 234 from the table
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you are opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
members should be in their seats we're
voting
foreign
members present had an opportunity to
vote
the house will attended the state of the
176 in the affirmative 170 and the
negative the
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker having voted on the
prevailing side I move that we
reconsider our vote of itl
and urge the membership to vote
yes
representative Weber moves
reconsideration of the igl vote on House
this will be a division vote members
for what reason to remember us a pi
please
a question about procedure
so this is a reconsideration I'm just
making sure that we're all following her
this is a motion to reconsider the all
to pass motion
the Ito yeah
was there a roll call before the
question
was there a roll call in the Ito
foreign
okay the motion is whether to reconsider
the ICL vote on House Bill 234
representative Weber is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I wish to
reconsider the motion of itl because I
want to vote no again would I now press
representative this is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
Mr Speaker
if I know that
reconsidering this vote
will take up even more time
on our day today
and that will be here until seven or
eight o'clock tonight reconsidering
every uh vote that we've made so far
this year when I press the red button
not to reconsider this boat this boat
representative Bowman we're in the
voting mode
no
the question is whether to reconsider
the ICL on House Bill 234 if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for
okay
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote
thou shall attended the state of the
vote
176 in the affirmative 169 and the
negative reconsideration passes
now back
we are now back to the inexperienced
legislative motion
and this will be a division vote members
protocol has been sufficiently
as and it is sufficiently seconded this
will be a roll call vote members still
[Music]
foreign
the question is inexperience a legislate
members should be in their seats we're
which I recognize representative
thank you Mr chair
I'm sorry Mr Speaker it's been a long
day I'm hangry
um thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that house bill 234 would end
a poison pill provision in statute that
authorizes State seizure of renewable
energy certificates without knowledge or
compensation to New Hampshire businesses
and residents and further Mr Speaker if
I know that that money is then given to
out-of-state large energy companies
instead of the New Hampshire citizens
who should rightfully have the money
from those certificates would I then
representative Bernard is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
adopting this bill would cost rate
payers another three million dollars
the question is in expedient to
legislate on House Bill 234 this is a
roll call vote if you are in favor
you'll press the red the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
sleeping
speakers
foreign
members present had an opportunity to
vote the house will attended the state
of the vote
170 in the affirmative 176 and the
for what reason does the member Mr
Speaker excuse me
Mr Speaker having voted on the
prevailing side of the
ought to pass vote on House Bill 234 I
more
reconsideration and urge my colleagues
alrighty the motion is reconsideration
on House Bill 234
okay and it is sufficiently seconded
[Music]
clear
the question is reconsideration of House
Bill 234 house will be in order we're in
if you are in favor of reconsideration
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
foreign
[Music]
had an opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
178 in the affirmative 169 and the
negative
Representatives
the house will be in order
you are all embarrassing yourselves and
all of your colleagues
here
okay
we're on the motion before us is ought
to pass on House Bill 234.
there's going to be a one-on-one debate
the chair recognizes representative
Bernardi
thank you Mr Speaker
so utilities are required to purchase a
certain amount of Renewable Power
and they can do that by
renewable energy wrecks or Alternative
Energy payments if they can't buy those
wrecks
so in order to do that
they compile from certain large
suppliers and get wrecks but they can
also buy from any one of you or myself
who happen to have some solar generation
in our backyard or on our rooftops
if we file the paperwork then they buy
those wrecks directly if we don't file
the paperwork and it's a significant
burden to do that
then the utilities by Statute are
so in the process of doing that
they do not then have to make those
Alternative Energy payments to make up
the amount of of renewable energy
credits that they need
so if we pass this bill we eliminate
that sweeping provision it means
utilities are going to have to make more
Alternative Energy payments
those payments are passed back to you
the rate payers directly goes right
straight through into your electric bill
this bill would would put about three
million dollars a year back into the
into the rate payers of New Hampshire
that is a
a direct harm to the rate payers and the
citizens of New Hampshire particularly
at a time
when electric rates are as high as they
are as they are so I urge you to vote
against this resolution against this
bill
chair recognizes representative Bank
Williams
House Bill 234
ends a bad statute
that's been on the books and should not
be harming New Hampshire ratepayers
the practice known as renewable energies
credit sweeping or wreck sweeping
enables private multi-billion dollar
out-of-state corporations and in-state
utilities to use New Hampshire residents
Rex rather than purchasing them as
they're obligated to do under law
multiple licensed New Hampshire
attorneys have concluded that this state
statute is an unconstitutional taking of
private property and violates the
takings clause in part 1 article 12 of
the New Hampshire Constitution this
property is not abandoned because
property only becomes abandoned under
New Hampshire law if is left unclaimed
for multiple years here the state seizes
the property at the time that it is
created there is no notice to the people
whose wrecks are being swept this
practice has helped ruin the wreck
market and should be overturned
therefore I ask for your vote to end
this unconstitutional law that we should
representative Sweeney has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
foreign
pass on House Bill 234 this is a roll
call vote chair recognizer
representative votes for a parliamentary
inquiry
billion dollars over the next 10 years
and if I know that renewable energy
certificates are the carrot in the
renewable portfolio standard they're the
incentive to get people to
create or acquire more renewable energy
and then if people don't use their
renewable energy certificates take
advantage of the incentive
there's no reason for it to exist
it isn't accomplishing anything
so finally if I know that taking away
the ability for utilities to clean these
unused wrecks
doesn't increase the supply of renewable
energy but costs ratepayers money
when I press the red button and vote no
on the motion of ought to pass thank you
Mr Speaker chair recognize your
representative McWilliams for
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr speaker if I know that three
million dollars of New Hampshire rate
payers money is going to out-of-state
corporations every year under this
existing statute without any notice
and further Mr Speaker if I know that
wreck sweeping is a practice that would
save us money in the long term by being
done away with because then we would be
able to use that money for investing in
other types of energy besides our
addiction to natural gas would I then
press green for ought to pass on this
motion thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 234 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
was president had an opportunity to vote
177 voting yay 167 voting a the motion
a committee on transportation to which
was referred House Bill 111 an act
establishing a committee to study
electrical vehicle charging for
residential renters have been considered
the same report the same with a fallen
resolution that is inexpedient to
legislate Senator John Sellers for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
I was supposed nay
yes
division has been called members take
foreign
vote
a house will be in order
division vote on House Bill 111.
the chair was uncertain as to The Voice
vote this will be a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press a green
button if your opposed will press a red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
O'Brien
representative
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
172 voting yay 174 voting a the motion
fails
what reason is memorize Mr Speaker I'd
like to move on to pass on HB 111.
the motion before us is ought to pass
our division division the motion before
us now is ought to pass on House Bill
foreign
motion before us is ought to pass in
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposal press the
red button voting stations for open for
foreign
was present had an opportunity to vote
175 voting a 172 voting day you ought to
pass motion pass passes
for what reason to remember rise uh
having voted on the prevailing side I'd
like to move reconsideration and urge my
the motion I can repeat it
the motion before us is to reconsider
house bill 111.
[Music]
representative Keller requests a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficient it is sufficiently
the motion before us is to reconsider
motion on House Bill 111
this will be a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press green if you're
opposed you'll press red voting stations
[Music]
representative
well members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend the state of the
vote
170 voting a 177 voting a motion for
reconsideration fails
foreign
these are the bills right now we're on
the bills removed from consent calendar
committee on criminal justice and Public
Safety to which it was deferred House
Bill 498 FN an act requiring Fish and
Game offices to obtain a warrant to
conduct a search and seizure considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate Senator
Jennifer Rhodes for the committee
having been the member who actually
increased the number of votes necessary
to pull something off a second I believe
I said during that speech that I had
overturned a 19-1 vote once before well
this is going to be a second attempt at
something like that
we're going to read a little bit just to
make sure everybody has background
regarding this bill
HB 498 page four in the calendar reads
and I quote the bill would have required
conservation officers to obtain a search
warrant for conducting any search
regarding their official duties that's
what the bill does in a nutshell
I'm going to read from part
from part first Article 19 of our
constitution
the agreement the citizens have with the
members of this state every subject has
a has a right to be secure from all
unreasonable searches and seizures
in his person his houses his papers and
his possessions
Fourth Amendment to the constant U.S
Constitution right a document that we
would not have signed had the Bill of
Rights not been included
the right of the people to be secure in
their persons houses papers and effects
against unreasonable searches and
seizures
what we have before us is a is a law
that was put in place in 1935 that's
been allowed to continue
the law
sorry the Constitution doesn't say with
the exception of Fish and Game officers
every right every citizen has a right to
be secure from unreasonable searches it
in 1935 they put in in law under RSA 206
26 certain powers for fish and game
to enforce all laws regulations rules
relating to Wildlife that's part of
their job that's reasonable
but further down on that same page it
says to stop stop and search without a
warrant and to examine in the field in
the highway and I'll get back to that
and in an air base or on the stream in
person or any boat conveyance aircraft
Etc
highway it's an interesting part of this
because just a few years ago we test
that same group
with enforcing all of the DMV laws
Fish and Game officers what do you
believe have more Authority than state
troopers
they have more Authority than sheriffs
they have more Authority than local law
enforcement officers
imagine for a moment someone has parked
their car over by Lake Massabesic
they're just sitting there having a
conversation
whether it's a State Trooper or or a
Manchester police officer sees the car
and wants to stop and talk to him
they're prohibited from going any
further they can't just arbitrarily say
I need to see inside your trunk but you
know what they can call the Fish and
Game officer who's monitoring the
fishing on that Lake and say hey I need
to look inside that guy's car
and the citizen doesn't have a right to
stop it
the Constitution put in very clear terms
that you need probable cause to go get a
warrant
the officers that oppose this from
student name said we can't do this we're
in the field and I have a great story to
that
my daughter and I for her 16th birthday
Ridge it's a long hike for those who
have done it it's a beautiful hike
it was a Friday it was 40 degrees at the
base and it was I don't know 10 degrees
with the 25 mile an hour wind at the top
it was a cold day
my iPhone battery died that day halfway
up the hill
it's coming down the hill my eye watch
went off I actually had a call from work
that I took in the midst of the woods
coming down the hill
with an eye watch
why does it matter with the technology
that exists today you can get a warrant
anywhere any place in New Hampshire
without a problem on a cell phone with
an email
my point there is if a why I watch can
transmit that level of information so
can a cell phone it is time to restore
back to the citizens the rights that are
duly
provided to us in the Constitution by
following the Constitution I would ask
that you would oppose the itl I would
like to send this back to the committee
that is the proper way to address this
bill but we'd have to get through an itl
motion first there is an amendment to
draft narrowly this to enforcement of
the DMV laws because the last section of
that chapter about enforcement of the
dnv laws is where the issue is thank you
I request a roll call vote
thank you Mr Speaker this was a
difficult bill for me I agree on
wholeheartedly on the question of
constitutional rights against search and
seizure
having said that it's not correct
we granted them the power to enforce
Motor Vehicle Laws because when they're
traveling to and fro across our states
in a marked police vehicle if they see
someone swerving over the lines prior to
giving that power they couldn't stop the
vehicle now they can stop the vehicle it
says they shall have the same powers and
duties as regular police officers
when they're enforcing Motor Vehicle
Laws regular police officers do not have
the power to just search a vehicle for
no reason
they have to get a warrant or they have
to have probable cause and there are
several exceptions to the warrant
requirement I'm not going to bore you
with all the legalese but there are
exceptions from the Supreme Court that
allow searches without a warrant one of
them being exigent circumstances
with regard to their powers it says it
they can't search for no reason the law
clearly says that they have to have a
clear and articulable reason to search
someone's fishing tackle or their boat
now the day of this hearing I want you
to know I came in and the room was
packed packed
with fishermen and Hunters
every one of them was there to oppose
this bill everyone said leave them alone
they're doing their job they're
protecting us they said our lobster
traps cost hundreds of dollars if they
were not out there doing the job we
could lose them
we'd be out of business they also said
they don't want to be held up for hours
at a time while Fish and Game tries to
get a warrant to go onto their boat they
were happy to do it there's a quid pro
quo exactly when you sign a thing to get
a fishing or hunting license you agree
to abide by and be a part of our
conservation system now he said since
1935 that's right not one person has
brought a case to the court that I'm
aware of that said they've acted
unconstitutionally not one person came
there except for the sponsor to testify
for this bill
if I believe for a second and the
members of my committee believe for a
second that they were abusing the powers
we gave them and let's remember we have
a responsibility to our constituents but
we have a responsibility to the agencies
that enforce the laws that we tell them
to
don't tell them to go out there and
protect our fishing stock when they
can't go over and ask a gentleman let me
see how many fish you got because the
other guy just said you've been fishing
here all day and you're only allowed to
get five
it they're only allowed to search
relative to The Fish and Game law what
they're looking at that doesn't mean
they can make the person strip it means
that they can look in their fishing
tackle box or or their creel or or what
have you so I would ask you to don't try
to fix a problem that's not there
if the if if someone does actually come
up and say hey they've abused me they
searched me without any right then we
look at it but right now there's not a
problem so please let's let them do
their jobs thank you
representative San Antonio has requested
a roll call and is sufficiently seconded
members take members take your seats
the motion before us is an expedient to
legislate on House Bill 498 this is a
roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button if your opposed will press a red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
233 voting a 113 voting a the committee
committee on Health and Human Services
in LD first which was referred House
Bill 598 FN an act relative to funding
maternal
mortality reviews having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is in expedient
to legislate Senator Gary Merchant for
the committee
what purpose is a memberize Mr Speaker I
raised I Rise to ask to table this bill
cabling is in order
I said the tabling motion is in order
thank you are you ready for the question
the motion before us is the table House
Bill 598 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
opposed nay your eyes have it in the
the committee on state and federal
relations and Veterans Affairs to which
was referred to h.7 not calling for the
federal government to preserve and
protect Medicare and Social Security
without cuts to benefits consider the
same report the same with a
recommendation of Bill ought to pass
president of Michael moffatt for the
committee
Murray has requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us has ought to pass
on HR 7. chair recognizes representative
if I know this measure was placed on the
consent calendar after our committee
voted unanimously
to support Social Security and Medicare
where I then press the green button to
support the committee's unanimous
OTP recommendation
thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before this is how to pass on
HR 7. this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
of your opposer press the red button
representative representative here are
you got to be in it we're still into
[Music]
foreign
333 voted yay
committee on state and federal relations
Veterans Affairs to which was referred
H.R 16 and act relative to the Internal
Revenue Service having considered the
same report the same following
resolution resolved that chair
H.R 16 is something near and dear to me
it would require the IRS to answer three
where and where is the word income
defined in the Internal Revenue code it
is not previous commissioners of the IRS
have already admitted that on tape
second where in the Internal Revenue
code is it written that the average
American who does not exercise a federal
privilege but simply trades his time for
money is liable to pay the federal
income tax and lastly why have numerous
Internal Revenue Service Publications
directors and members of the United
States Congress
among others stated that the income tax
is voluntary
time is the most precious resource we
have
and we can give back to our constituents
a huge chunk of time that they pay in
money
and also time to fill out these numerous
contradictory complicated and useless
forms
the income tax code is 74 000 pages long
no one in here has read it I'm willing
to wager that
so the question is has anyone in here
read it and have they actually
into position is an interesting concept
that I would just like to talk about and
relates to this
this is in Merriam-Webster's Dictionary
it's the action of a state whereby its
sovereignty is placed between the
citizen and the federal government
it is our duty to step in the breach
between and out of control federal
government and the individual citizens
monstrosity Goliath from Simply
trampling all of our rights
we can get it I don't want to get into
the nuances of why the federal income
tax doesn't apply to the average
American you guys wouldn't care and it's
not worth the time but the simple fact
is the IRS is not open to actually
discussing this and I think it's
necessary for us
to bring this question up and to force
the issue because the second we do that
is the second we release all of those
resources that are being wasted because
none of the federal income tax money
actually goes to us it goes to pay the
interest on a national debt to the
privately owned Federal Reserve so it's
complete waste of time and it's against
all of our principles no matter where
article 14 legal remedies to be free
complete and prompt
every subject of this stays entitled to
a certain Remedy by having recourse of
the laws for all injuries he may receive
in his person property or character to
obtain right and Justice freely without
being obliged to purchase it completely
and without any denial promptly and
without delay conformably to the laws
and we're being denied that by the
federal government through their
agents
at the IRS
lastly I want to quote
old Danny over there Daniel Webster
in famous Supreme Court decision
McCulloch verse Maryland he wrote he
said in unwell he wrote in Unlimited
power to tax
involves necessarily a power to destroy
and I would argue that the federal I
don't want to call them politics
whatever the federal people at this at
the top level
have endeavored to destroy us slowly and
through a corrupt income tax system and
I'm simply just asking you for your
support to get this question answered
and well these questions and lastly
in 2021 I brought this issue up at the
town meeting in my town and my
representative who's here I don't want
to point him out
he said that this is an issue for
Concord and not for this the select
board or town meeting so here I am I
went through all the effort and now I'm
here so I appreciate your support and I
but does the member yield the questions
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you so
much for taking my question are you
aware that under the Republican
president General former General
Eisenhower the marginal tax rate in this
country was 92 percent
I would argue that
house will be in order
thank you Mr Speaker
the sponsor among other things used the
term average American
average American was not clear to the
committee what constituted an average
American
uh is the committee report stated which
you should all have access to this
proposed resolution sought to make the
case the sponsor just sought to make the
case that certain IRS
Internal Revenue practices are extra
legal
but that flies in the face of the
Constitution the 16th Amendment to the
Constitution
like it or not it clearly sanctions a
federal income tax as well as numerous
other
subsequent codes and statutes and
levied at the uh at different levels so
the committee voted 16-1 to recommend
itl and places measure on the consent
calendar thank you Mr Speaker and I will
the motion before us is inexp meeting to
legislate an H.R 16.
roll call Representative San Antonio
Crystal roll call us at sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us is any speeding to
this is going to be a roll call vote
chair recognized representative Gerhart
if I knew that the Federal Government
utilizes special definitions otherwise
known as terms of art within the
Internal Revenue code to obfuscate what
they're doing
such as the term wages being defined as
for purposes of this chapter the term
wages means all remuneration other than
fees paid to a public official for
services performed by an employee for
his employer
employee being described as for purposes
of this chapter the term employee
includes an officer this is this is a
parliamentary inquiry if I knew that the
term employee is defined as for
personality includes an officer employee
or elected official of the United States
the state or any political subdivision
thereof or the District of Columbia or
an agency exceptionally it goes on has
nothing to do with us then I if I was to
know
that these are questions that our
constituents want to be answered and if
I know that I went door-to-door in my
district and asked people and this was
one of the three planks I would vote
no on the itl and bring these questions
do you recognize representative Moffett
thanks again Mr Speaker if I know that
our house committee on state of federal
relations and Veterans Affairs
recommended itl by a 16-1 vote and
issued a report to that effect stating
the 16th Amendment to the United States
Constitution clearly sanctions of
federal income tax that would I then
support the committee's recommendation
by pressing the green button
the motion before us is inexpinning to
legislate and house bill 16. it's the
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
or press the red button voting stations
the wall members president had an
opportunity to vote I also attend a
283 voting yay 60 voting May committee
reporters adopted
the chair recognizes the member from
Auburn for the third reading motion
question
thank you Mr Speaker resolved at the
house now adjourned from the early
session that the business of the late
session be in order at the present time
that the reading of bills be by title
only and resolutions by caption only
then all bills ordered the third reading
we read a third time by this resolution
that all titles of bills be the same as
adopted and that they'd be passed at the
present time and when the house adjourns
today it be to meet at the call of the
chair
question is on the third
the question is on the third reading
motion I read it for the question all
those in favor say aye those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted
house will attend to announcements
recognize the clerk
thank you Mr Speaker just a reminder
please for members to please clean out
your seat pockets and also please clean
out your mailboxes on your way home this
evening
we're going into Nana's consent please
be seated don't run out the door yet
the chair recognizes representative
thank you Mr Speaker
if you are of African black African
descent would you please join me here
please
Mr Speaker and honorable colleagues I
Rise for a unanimous unanimous consent
to recognize Black History Month and pay
tribute to past and current members of
the legislature of African descent here
in New Hampshire
you may ask why celebrate Black History
Month it's a way of remembering our true
past appreciating our present and
Imagining the possibilities of the
future
Africans were brought here to America
and changed over 300 years ago although
they helped to build this country they
endured centuries of being treated as
mayor property and a slave unable to
experience freedom
unable to engage in free enterprise or
even be taught to read or write
in 1857 New Hampshire declared that no
one shall be denied citizenship on
account of African descent and along
with Vermont
repealed laws against the enlistment of
blacks and state militia
in 1863 the Emancipation Proclamation
freed all slaves in a 1965 the 13th
amendment abolished slavery in all
states
110 years later New Hampshire elected
the first black American to the New
Hampshire State legislation
and it was a privilege to have his
daughter here this morning for uh
Minister Renee Rouse
ping is Henry B Richardson from
Greenville
Henry Richardson was a retired army
major he served in the military for 31
years
served in three Wars and was decorated
24 times
he achieved the rank of major when he
retired
Henry B Richardson won the Republican
nomination for his party in 1974.
he was elected in 1975 and served one
term
the first African-American the first
Native American the first 19 year old
all happened during that same time after
serving two years in the New Hampshire
house The Honorable Henry Richardson ran
for state senate and was even endorsed
by Manchester Union leader
at this time I like to read all some of
the names and those have been here for a
very long time will probably remember
them probably served on committees with
them so again the first one was The
Honorable Henry Ward Richardson from
Greenville
1975 to 1977 the first African-American
male to serve in the legislature
The Honorable Linda long very dear
friend of mine she was from Nashua first
female African-American New Hampshire
legislator
served in 1987 to 1989
The Honorable Lionel Johnson of
Manchester the longest serving
African-American here and served in the
house
1989 to 2003 from Manchester
The Honorable Juanita Bell
from Nashua
1989-1993.
The Honorable Jackie Witherspoon from
Exeter
1997 to 1999
and The Honorable Harvey King from
um
The Honorable Claire Clark from Boston
The Honorable Chris Roberts from Keene
2005-2015.
the Reverend Gene Judy Manchester
the honorable James Lawrence from Hudson
2006 to 2008.
The Honorable Carol Estes from Plymouth
2007-2009.
The Honorable Melanie Levick from
The Honorable caroletta Alicea
honorable Claire Clark's daughter from
Boston
2012-2018 and then again 2020 to 2022.
representative Linda Harrier gathwright
myself from Nashua
2017 to current
the Reverend Charlotte dilorenzo from
and newly elected representative Damon
and representative Jonah wheeler from
Peterborough 2022.
[Applause]
and I might I'm not sure if I left I
left two out I think I don't think I
mentioned uh The Honorable Roger Johnson
from I did because him okay when I
didn't was The Honorable Richard Comey
and he was from Manchester Kumi he was
2019 to 2011.
so for quite a few of these people are
now deceased and if you would stand for
a moment in a moment of silence
represent you know in recognition of the
service that they gave to the state of
so today we we stand in recognition of
all these Representatives cited for for
their achievements and their service to
the state of New Hampshire not only for
blazing a trail and being a role model
to what is achievable but for
transcending barriers of race and greed
it is important to note that New
Hampshire house is a diverse Fellowship
of legislators
and that we all deserve to be here and
more importantly we were elected I pray
because of our character and our
willingness to serve
that's it thank you
[Applause]
well what ways does a member rise Mr
Speaker I move the members remarks be
placed in the permanent journal without
objection
chair recognizes the representative
Phyllis asked me to read the marks
yeah
thank you Mr Speaker and good afternoon
colleagues
Robert Bob fesch 85 of Derry New
Hampshire passed away on Tuesday
December 20th 2022.
surrounded by Rosemary his wife of 52
years
and his two sons Randy and John
Bob was born June 7 1937 and was raised
and educated in Bethel Connecticut
graduated in 1955.
in high school he started soccer
baseball basketball track and field
where he was the state champion in the
javelin
from there Bob attended Niagara
University on an athletic scholarship
for basketball and baseball
and was the baseball Most Valuable
Player as a freshman
Bob was the state representative serving
Dairy for 30 years
he served on the regulated Revenue
criminal justice and Public Safety
committees
he was also a member of Rockingham
County executive committee
in town politics he was also oops Gary
and child politics he was a member of
the dairy budget committee Highway
Safety Committee
School advisory committee and the police
building committee
to round things out
he served as the president of the Derry
Fraternal Order of the Eagles Social
Club
hmm
if you stayed out of trouble
Bob was a lifelong Sports Enthusiast and
a fan who loved his Boston teams second
only to watching his own Sons Sports
Endeavors
in their early years he spent countless
hours after school teaching and playing
baseball and basketball with them
he coached several successful teams in
their youth and the further teaching his
children and their teammates the skills
and love of the sports that he had
when he wasn't watching or coaching
sports or legislating you could find Bob
at home and join his family
tinkering with various projects around
the house or coconut grilling for his
wife and family
mom was I
a tireless worker who sought to instill
in his children his strong work habits
sense of responsibility knowledge
know-how
it was during this teachings
that his love of his children family and
life Shone brightest
in his later years he cherished beingeth
grandfather as he and Rose would often
babysit
or take the children to the park
grandchildren lastly Bob enjoyed in
going down to the hail Sand Club
another fun place
to have a beer a drink
play cards and hang out with his friends
he'll be deeply missed by his friends
and his family thank you we all stand
[Music]
foreign
Mr Speaker I would move that the
memorial remarks be placed in the
permanent journal without objection
thank you Mr chair I'm going to make
some remarks about the sacrifice of the
soldiers in Ukraine and I invite any
it's okay it's
democracy is always one only with great
sacrifice and once lost it is incredibly
difficult to win back that's why 74
years ago the Democratic countries of
NATO agreed that a threat against one
was a threat against all and why today
41 countries are assisting Ukraine
so on this one year anniversary of the
Russian invasion please stand for a
moment of silence to honor the tens of
thousand courageous Ukrainian soldiers
and civilians who have given their lives
in defense of self-governance because in
doing so they have died defending all
thank you Mr Speaker
today I Rise to talk a little bit about
our constitution
I like all of us in this room took an
oath to the constitution of New
Hampshire
my favorite article is article 65 which
urges us to foster a civil uh Foster a
civil society
but
what I'm going to talk about today is
article 12 which tell of part one which
tells us that we are obliged to provide
prevent protections to the citizens of
the state and in order to pay for those
product protections we are obliged to
tax
Representatives the duty of Taxation
Falls to us
it denigrates each and every one of us
and the Constitution that we swore to
protect when someone calls us thieves by
saying that taxation is theft
protection
Okay so
thank you
the question before us now is shall the
this is going to be a division vote
[Music]
absolutely
members take your seats
the motion is shall the member continue
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button for your opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
here
ball members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
145 voting a 127 voting a the motion
fails to attain the two-thirds
three-fifths I'm sorry
chair recognizes representative
adjective
for what reason to memorize
thank you Mr Speaker I just wanted to
rise to ask that we place in the
permanent journal the remarks of the
member from wholeness
highlighting the heroism of the people
of Ukraine thank you without objection
thank you Mr Speaker
I'd like to tell you about an individual
in order to set the context for my
remarks today
one of my great political Heroes was the
longest serving speaker of the United
States House of Representatives
and the man's name was Sam Rayburn
and when Sam Rayburn was Speaker of the
House
it was a time where my party was not as
ideologically United as it is today
and a reporter once asked him Mr Speaker
are you a liberal Democrat or a
conservative Democrat
and Sam rayburn's answer was I am not
either of those
said I am a Democrat without prefix
suffix or apology
and that is how I've operated here
however I tell you that
in order to set the context for a thank
you and congratulations to the
Republican floor leader
uh today oftentimes was very contentious
a lot going on a lot of moving Parts
um but throughout the whole time he and
I have been in communication
have had a little fun made some light of
some of the things today uh and I
consider him now a good friend and I
look forward to meeting on this field of
battle for a long and probably tiring
year but thank you for your new
camaraderie
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
for what reason does a member rise Mr
Speaker I moved to place the remarks of
my counterpart Deputy floor leader on
the Democratic side in the apartment
Journal please without objection
representative Osmond moves at the house
standing recess for the purpose of the
introduction of pills and Road build
amendments and Road Bill reports and
receiving messages you're ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it and
the motion is adopted the house is in